This is Jocko podcast number
94 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
The black cloud of smoke exploded silently
outside the open door of the Dakota
obscuring for the moment my view of the
geometrical Dutch landscape deserted,
but for a few for Lauren cows.
As soon as the sea,
it appeared below us.
I started to think about the flack and I
knew that everyone else in the aircraft
must be worrying as well.
Okay.
When we crossed the
east Anglican coastline,
that slight wave of movement
had flickered down the aircraft.
As the men check their watches,
calculating the time it would take to
fly over the sea and come within range of
the now alerted German antiaircraft guns
below us.
The air sea rescue launches of the RAF
dotting the water at precise intervals
were pleasantly comforting.
The narrow band of beach,
which was the coast of Holland,
had aroused us once again.
As the flooded fields flashed into view,
private Harrison had leaned across to
point out the guns and the ground shooting
up at the massed ranks of our aircraft.
At the sound of my Batman's voice,
which had been silent for the past hour.
The men near to the open
doorway had craned forward
to see what they could while
the rest anxious for the first indications
of the enemy had twisted their next
appear through the small
windows at their backs.
At first I could see nothing
and I was stupidly aggravated
that everyone but myself
could spot gun flashes.
Then came that cloud of smoke
producing an odd sense of satisfaction,
a reaction which immediately shamed me.
This was the behavior of
a small boy for all that.
It was satisfying not
to feel scared by it.
Perhaps it was because the
experience was not only novel,
but in some way impersonal.
Looking down the dark tunnel of the
aircraft at the double line of soldiers.
It was a relief to see that all
traces of nervousness at disappeared.
We had been waiting a long time for this.
So that is the opening of a
book called men at our Nim
and it was actually sent to me by a guy
by the name of James of federal and the
book was originally published under the
pseudonym Tom Angus and it was about
this battle at this place called
[inaudible], which is in Holland.
And in the book, the units that are doing
the fighting, they're not identified,
they don't say what units they are.
But shortly after the book was published
it became very clear and it was
revealed that the author was an
individual named Jeffrey Powell,
a British army officer and that the
unit that the book talks about was the
hundred and 56th parachute
battalion of the British army
who fought against all odds
and really with misfortune after
misfortune for eight days during Operation
Market Garden,
which is a famous world war two operation,
a bold and super aggressive plan and
also the largest airborne operation up
until that point.
And the goal was to isolate parts of
the German forces and to cut off what's
known as the rare district, which is
like the heart of German industry.
And then open up a route going
from through that whole area,
take control of the roads and the bridges
and be able to punch right into the
heart of Germany.
Over 40,000 airborne troops
took part in the operation,
including America's 82nd airborne
and the 104 first airborne divisions.
But the deepest, the, those that
jump deepest into enemy territory,
we're from the British British
first Airborne Division,
and that included this battalion,
the hundred and 56th parachute battalion.
And if you know anything
about Operation Market Garden,
although it did achieve
some beneficial things,
overall,
the mission was considered a failure
because it didn't actually achieve the
objectives that it wanted to achieve.
And as you can imagine,
those that were furthest out suffered
some absolutely catastrophic casualties
and people taken prisoner
and people killed in action.
Hm.
And, and this is only an eight day.
This is eight days long. So this,
this period that we're about to cover
is only eight days long and you're going
to see that it is,
it is vicious and the names
were changed in this book,
but again,
this is an accountant,
an account from one of the company
commanders inside this battalion.
Okay.
So obviously the opening was them flying
over to the English Channel and getting
ready to jump in to Holland. And
here we go. Back to the book,
I braced myself with the open door,
the first man in the stick to jump
gripping the fuselage and in case a sudden
jerk flung me out too soon,
leaning forward,
the wind whipped my face pouring over the
details of the plastic Dutch landscape
below.
I could now see one or two
cyclists dotting the otherwise
deserted countryside.
The flicker of the red warning light
near my face told me that there was one
minute to go.
Okay.
A railway line flashed blow the pattern
of the woods was familiar as the view of
the stable yard from the office window.
The air photographs and the briefing
model of the ground had imprinted the
shapes on my mind.
The pilots were dead on target.
More often than not. In the old
days we had been dropped a stray,
but these yanks always
learned from their mistakes.
I never saw the red light turn to green.
Harrison's hand slapped my shoulder.
I was out of the door.
The slip stream hit me flicking me
sideways and I fell away just catching a
glimpse of Harrison in the air above me
and the tail of the aircraft flashing
out of sight.
Then I was floating,
suspended gently in midair.
My parachute canopy, hi,
I looked up at the sky, choked with
hundreds of swaying parachutes.
Most of them pattern didn't
green and brown camouflage,
but other others in a galaxy of
colors, red and orange, purple,
blue and yellow,
vivid against the scattered white clouds.
Every moment more aircraft
arrived arrived to disgorge,
their car goes into the crowded air.
Then I noticed the humming we were
being shot at from the ground.
There were Boesch on the drop zone.
Something was badly wrong and opposed
landing with the enemy firing as we hung
from our parachutes,
parachutes or tried to collect our
weapons before we could gather into a
cohesive force on the ground was something
new for us in the British airborne
forces.
Okay.
So as they're coming down,
they're getting shot at,
he uses this term throughout the
book, he calls the German Boesch, B,
O, c, h, e,
and where it comes from,
from what I gathered,
there's a French word that means
it could mean head like caboshing
or something like that.
And it also can mean cabbage.
And so I guess they're,
they're their slang term,
they're derogatory slang term was these
big headed German big cabbage heads and
he reduced that down to this term Boesch.
And it's a common one for them to use.
They used it a lot in world war one. And
so this is, this is a hangover from that,
but you're gonna hear
it throughout the book.
That's how he's referring to the Germans.
Back to the book of sharp pain burned.
The knuckles of my left hand blood
was seeping from my fingers. A bullet.
Must've hit me,
grazed me anyway,
but now the heath land was rushing up,
raising my hands to lift the webs.
I pulled and then hit the,
and then the ground hit me with an
uncomfortable jar, a bad landing.
I lay in the sunken road listening
to the bullets cracking overhead,
and they're right there. They
get right into the mix. I mean,
it's immediately into the mix.
Obviously they're getting shot at and
the wig down and then as soon as they hit
the ground, it's on back to the
book of Man with bloodstream.
Bloodstains shell dressing
wrapped around his throat,
walked around the corner of the
walking towards us just as Pritchard,
who's a medic,
finished his work.
Then came a couple of
parties carrying stretchers,
the occupant of one unconscious,
the other with a cigarette
between his gray tight lips.
They were the first stream of wounded
men from a variety of units making their
painful way towards the dressing station,
which had been set up in the
woods behind us so far. See,
company had been lucky only for men
were missing and a fifth that turned up
late, smiling cheerfully. Despite
a bullet through his bandaged arm.
Another four or five were limping and
hopping about on strained or twisted
ankles,
expressions of disgust in their faces,
victims of the gusty wind
on the droppings zone.
Okay.
All of them would have to be left behind.
But then I thought again,
calculating the figures once more,
perhaps we had not been so lucky after
all a 10th of the men who had in plane
that morning were already casualties.
It,
it sounded as if all the fighting had
happened on the far side of the droppings
zone in the Arnhem jerk direction.
Now the noise of the battle began to ebb.
The enemy posts had probably been overrun.
Neither news nor orders had arrived
from battalion headquarters,
but I knew better than to obstruct
the radio net with needless questions.
So first of all,
you're rolling into a situation where you,
you're on your insert and you
lose 10% of your men that that's,
that's just where you're starting
to. Now, if I remember correctly,
that is the standard kind of figure that
when you're conducting a big airborne
operation, like when the army
conducts big airborne operations,
that's what they figure they're going
to take for casualties on the drop zone.
Obviously they usually do better than
that, but for worst case scenarios,
that's kind of what they figure
and that's where they're at.
The other thing that I thought
was cool is here he is,
he hasn't heard any word
from the battalion HQ yet,
but he's not going to jump on
the net and saying, hey boss,
what do you want me to do? Hey, what's
going on? Hey, where do want me to be?
Because there's other people that are
trying to talk and he's got to just kind
of figure things out.
At this point,
now he's talking about his own company,
but here's the report on the net on the
rest of the battalion as he learned,
as he figured itself and as usual.
Obviously I'm not reading the whole book
and I'm skipping through big chunks of
combat situations,
but at this point he figures out
what's going on with the battalion.
Going back to the book. Casualties
in the battalion had not been light.
Two officers and a hundred men
had failed to arrive among them.
The plane load,
which we had seen shot down
another load had probably been
dropped in the wrong place.
Ian Hampshire was one of the missing
officer's rumor had it that he was dead.
The other was the intelligence
officer whose job Jimmy Gray had.
Now combined with his own, Jimmy could
not explain the reason for the delay.
No one seemed to know,
and that's one of the parts that I
didn't go over it in the beginning of the
book. As they're flying in, as they're
seeing flack hit and explode around them,
you know,
they see another one of their aircraft
filled with their brothers go down,
no shoots.
Hmm.
Now they start getting some coherent
input from the battalion and,
and here's what they figured out.
Going back to the book,
we would move as had already
been planned in England,
the leading company of the battalion,
we've Leslie Doyle's platoon
number nine in the front,
some 200 yards ahead,
followed by company headquarters.
Then Luke Tyler's eight
platoon. Then Douglas Thompson,
seven platoon at the back.
As I had expected,
the company was ready to move.
By the time orders had been given out,
two minutes.
We're all that was needed for the men
to slide there and trenching tools into
place, pick up their weapons
and sort themselves out.
No one had removed his equipment.
It was a lesson which the
colonel had drummed into us.
No Man must ever remove his equipment
when the enemy is anywhere near,
no matter whether he was digging,
sleeping, or deprecating,
whatever time it may be,
day or night,
a soldier had only to reach for his
weapon to be ready to fight or to march.
Just once this day,
just once each day,
one man in three at a time was allowed
to strips so that he could wash and shave
and shave.
They must.
Okay.
The last man of nine platoon
was disappearing around
the corner of the sandy
track, which ran parallel with
the railway line to our Nim.
When I noticed the colonel standing on
the right next to the shell of a still
smoking glider,
which partly blocked the battalion's path.
So there was paratroopers that came in,
but other people came in on gliders,
just big gliders, you know, no engine
that would get towed by other planes.
They're filled with men and they
were just land these gliders in,
in big open fields.
Hmm,
okay.
Gray was by the kernel side and behind
them crouched to not have radio operators
and orderlies.
It was the same as ever.
The colonel's eyes were still,
but he never missed anything.
The unfastened pouch from which a grenade
or brand magazine could slip the slack
Chin Strap,
which would fail to hold a running man
steel helmet in place quietly there,
colonel would indicate the error to
whichever passing officer NCO was
responsible for the man.
Nothing was ever ignored.
Safely out of range. The offender would
mumble about the nitpicking old bastard.
But the abuse was usually
perfunctory and good natured,
all of the new his ways. And by now
they had learned that his fads mattered.
So the colonel's running a tight ship.
That's what he's doing.
He's a highly disciplined
guy and he keeps his,
keeps his troops in check and as you
can see they're not offended by that.
Like they, they, they complain about
it a little bit, but they also,
they also know it's the right thing to do.
Here we go back to the book, although
we were moving along our planned route,
our role in the battle had been changed
instead of making for the high ground
north of our Nem,
the whole of the brigade was now marching
for the PR for the bridge to relieve
the struggling remnants
of the first brigade,
which had been fighting alone
there for more than 24 hours.
One thing was certain, so, so they're,
their mission had changed
a little bit there.
A Bridge and First Brigade was at
this bridge, had taken the bridge,
but now they're getting attacked at that
bridge by the Germans and there and now
these guys get this brigade gets the
orders to go and help them go and relieve
them. Back to the book. One thing
was certain parachute infantry.
We're not the fast moving hard hitting
troops depicted by the daily press with
no more transport in a battalion and then
for lightly armored carriers and some
half dozen jeeps.
Nearly everything needed in battle
either had to be carried on the backs of
soldiers or dragged behind them.
There were no trucks just behind the
forward companies loaded with spare
ammunition.
Instead,
extra bandoliers were strung around necks
and light anti tank mines swung from
waist belts.
Success came with surprise
in this sort of fighting,
the enemy must be caught unaware and
crushed before they could recover.
Inevitably,
we would run short of ammunition if
the Boesch we're allowed the chance of
standing and fighting.
This weary trudge toward the bridge and
our Nem along the endless tracks was a
crazy way to use airborne troops.
Surprise had been lost long ago
before the operation started.
I doubted the wisdom of dropping
so far from the bridges.
Now it was clear that it had
been a mistake, so they're,
they're in a radically
different situation.
Instead of dropping in and holding
some ground, now they're moving.
They have to carry all their gear
with them. It's not a good situation.
He's talking about some of the guys are
carrying it as much as a hundred pounds,
which is a ton of weight
and now they get,
they get word from the
kernel back to the book.
He was able to confirm that
the first parachute brigade,
we're still holding out the bridge where
the casualties had been heavy on both
sides.
The Germans having already lost 2000 men,
although it was not clear
who had counted them.
Now as he gets done with that,
he kind of gives some word,
they're going to start
moving down this track.
So he's giving that order to this.
One of his officers,
Doyle and Doyle's normally,
you know,
pretty pretty fired up
about what he's doing.
He's a motivated guy and here we go.
Back to the book,
Doyle was not at all
his in bullying itself.
The task of nine platoon was simple.
He and his men had to walk straight down
the track until they ran into the bush
position.
Their first warning of the enemy presence
would be the rifle and machine gun
fire tearing into them.
Still less were the two scouts to be
envied who would be moving out in front of
the rest of the platoon.
It was almost inevitable that the first
German rounds would hit one or both of
them,
unless the Germans were cunning enough
to let them pass so as to kill more of
the men behind,
but without armor in front to draw the
enemy fire and pinpoint their positions.
There was no other way to advance.
I had chosen Doyle to lead the advance
because I was certain that I could rely
on him.
This was the penalty for
being good at one's job.
So there you go.
They're actually walking down train
tracks and they know 100% they know 100%
that Germans are waiting for them and
they're going to push down the tracks and
the way they're going to find the Germans
is when the Germans start shooting at
them.
Yeah.
So they proceed down the tracks
and now going back to the book,
the expected happen happened the column
of the night collapse in an explosion of
light and noise from a wide arc in
front of nine platoon streams of white,
red and yellow tracer bullets converged
on the stretch of track where the men
must have flung themselves to the ground.
Very lights and parachute flares larger
and brighter than anything carried by us,
swung down towards the earth,
lighting the dark country shy
to the shade of gray of a gray.
November morning, a house burst into
flames on the other side of the railway.
It was too sudden for an accident.
The conflagration must've been planned.
Anything which moved was now visible.
Overall was the noise,
the din of shells and mortars bursting
both behind and ahead merging with the
harsh roar of this enemy Spandau light
machine guns and the more sustained
drumming of the heavier weapons.
Now I could hear another sound.
It was a slow rat,
a tat tat of nine put tunes,
Bren guns and the crack of British
rifles replying to the German fire.
Okay.
There are a lot of enemy in front of us.
The Germans had men everywhere.
So this is like a well planned ambush
scenario and if you think about it,
they had,
it sounds like they rigged this house
to light up and and be on fire and now
that's backlighting and silhouetting
all the friendly troops because it just
makes you stand out because
it's a fire behind you
on top of that machine gun fire on top
of that mortar shells are hating you.
And here we go back to the book as as
okay
as the major here as
the company commander,
Jeffry Powell is his crouched down waiting
as all this is happening out ahead of
him. He's not with that first platoon.
He's behind them a little bit.
And here we go.
Back to the book,
I saw a single crouched figure running
up the track behind towards me.
Then I recognize the broad bulk of Barf,
Bartholomew,
Leslie Doyle's platoon sergeant.
This was quick.
Leslie had wasted no timing, sending
back news. Only a little out of breath.
Sergeant Bartholomew sank down
by my side and began to speak.
His voice is calm and sensible as usual
is leading section would come under fire
at a range of only some 20 or 30 yards.
It appeared that the Germans had allowed
the two scouts to pass on molested,
but everyone else in the
front section had been killed.
Okay.
There were several other casualties in
the platoon as well, including Mr. Doyle,
who had been hit badly in the Fi,
and it was only semi-conscious.
The survivors were pinned
to the ground by fire,
which was coming from
either side of the track.
This was all wrong with
his platoon commander,
hit Sergeant Bart, follow them,
you, his place was with the platoon.
There were plenty of other people
to carry messages. Not only that,
but Bartholomew could hardly have had
time to verify the disastrous information
about the leading section.
It was far too light,
far from likely that every
man in it had been killed.
So Bartholomew's nerve had
broken in the first test.
So that's a situation this guy ran and
he comes back and reports in and says,
you know, hey, everyone's
dead. And he's, he realizes
he, the company commander
realizes that not true.
Going back to the book, perhaps the
responsibility had been too much for him.
Whatever it was.
He was certainly scared despite a success
in concealing the fact the sergeant
had run away leaving the
platoon to its own devices.
I was flabbergasted of all the end pose.
I had judged this cool reserved
man to be the most dependable,
a hard taskmaster,
too ruthless to be popular.
Sergeant Bartholomew had been an effective
foil to the easy going and friendly
Doyle and the two men
had formed a fine team.
It was incredible that
this should have happened
in the light of a flare.
I studied the sergeants face.
There was nothing to be seen.
Bartholomew returned my
glaze with steady eyes.
There could be no point in my further
destroying the man's self. Self respect.
It was possible that he might
recover after this first shock.
Has Pride taking charge
to control his fear?
Yeah,
so my rebuke was restrained no more than
a comment that Bartholomew illustrative
sent private Jones back with
the news and not come himself.
Then I stood up once again told Robert
who had appeared by my side to take
charge and started down the
track toward the forward platoon,
motioning Bart following
meal to accompany me.
There was no need to say
anything to Harrison who
automatically rose to his feet.
His sten cradled in his
elbow ready to shoot.
So interesting leadership dynamic there.
Instead of saying you coward,
you quit, he doesn't do that.
Instead he, he really tones it back and
says he should have said Jones instead.
He's hoping that this guy will
recover and this is a great line.
His pride taking charge
to control his fear,
meaning this guy just has
no pride at this point.
He's trying to keep it together,
but hopefully the cap,
the,
the company commander is
thinking that, okay, this guy,
we'll get it back together hopefully
and we'll be able to utilize them as
opposed to me just dropping
the hammer on him right now.
In which case he might just
completely break and be worthless.
And the other thing, and I, I tried to
include as much as I could have this guy,
Harrison, that gets mentioned, who's
sort of the the the company commanders,
right hand guy, but he's just
always there, always ready,
always stepping up and
making things happen.
Hmm.
Now,
eventually as all that unfolds,
we're going back to the book Nesbitt,
which is one of the guys in that,
in that platoon,
Nesbitt had decided that it was time to
leave and had used the lol to bring back
the survivors of the platoon.
Two men were dead.
While nothing was known of the fate,
the two scouts with Nesbitt,
we're five wounded men,
two of whom including his officer were
being carried Leslie and shocking pain
from a shattered fi,
which morphea had done little to help,
had fainted after a few yards
and was still unconscious.
A third of the platoon were casualties.
It was bad,
but not as quite as bad as
pictured by Bartholomew.
I could not blame Nesbitt for
withdrawing without permission.
Short of ammunition with their officer
wounded and the platoon sergeant
unaccountably missing.
The men had heard nothing of the troops
behind them for the past hour and had
concluded that the battalion
must've pulled back.
Nesbitt had seen a lot of war as this DCM.
One in Crete testified.
He understood it's muddle.
He knew it was rare for a
battle to go as planned.
His responsibility was to his men to
rescue them from what seemed to be a mess.
This he had done and his
judgment had been correct.
They were no place to
be caught at daylight,
overlooked on a forward slope and
unencumbered with wounded men.
So you see decentralized command in
action right there. Nesbitt doesn't here.
It doesn't know what's going on.
He makes a decision.
I'm getting these guys out of here and
what's good is the company commander
supports, Hey, do he made a good
call? That was the right thing to do.
Hmm.
Now at this point,
they're moving backed.
They're moving back after
they've confirmed, you know,
they'd pushed forward trying to find out
where the Germans were and now they're
moving back because they realize that the
Germans are absolutely holding strong.
So they'd had done this push forward.
They've got basically ambushed
and now they'd pulled back after,
you know,
like I said,
confirming where the Germans were back
to the book to accomplish this meaning to
accomplish finding out where the Germans
were to accomplish this had cost us
Leslie Doyle and the
absent bar following meal,
while two men and Doyle's leading
section were dead and the two scouts were
missing,
probably either killed or made prisoner,
seven other men had been wounded,
including another sergeant.
This was a total of 13 casualties with
another nine men lost when we landed with
nothing at all accomplished over 20 men
had already been killed or injured and
now the battalion was moving in the
wrong direction back the way we had come.
Okay,
and you're going to, you're going to find,
I mean, this is what makes this story so
d so devastating is that it?
You know,
I talk about Murphy's law and things
go wrong. These guys are complete.
It's just Murphy's law
over and over again and
okay.
In most of the books that we read on here,
there's triumph and there's
a victory at the end.
And you can see right now already where
this has headache and we got 20 guys
wounded or killed and instead of moving
forward, we're actually moving backward.
Hmm.
Back to the book. Sooner than expected,
we reached the battalion base.
It had been cited in a rectangular patch
of wood about 20 acres inside line just
north of the railway.
Okay.
It was 2:30 AM a horrible hour especially.
So if one is tired,
cold and hungry,
thank God it would be starting to
get light and a couple of hours.
What would happen tomorrow?
Something had gone very wrong indeed
by now we should be dug in on the high
ground north of art, him waiting for the
Germans to counter attack the bridges.
Instead we were sitting here in the
woods only a few miles from where we had
dropped with strong enemy forces between
ourselves and the city where the men of
First Brigade must be
fighting for their lives.
Wherever one turned. There seem to be
German troops and good ones at that.
The men who had stopped us,
had not behaved like rear area troops
scrape together to put up some sort of
resistance,
but it fought with skill and tenacity.
The slit trenches were dug and everyone
except for the double centuries in each
section and the officers and
NCOs on duty was sound asleep.
The men hump like dogs,
some curled up with a companion for
warmth lying in their full equipment,
their weapons tied to
their risks by the slings.
I should be asleep to
not sitting in worrying,
feeling sorry for myself,
for trying to get some rest and
preparation for the coming day.
Stand to would be at zero for 30 hours,
half an hour before first light when
everyone would be awake and ready and this
slit weapon poised for
a possible dawn attack.
So they're dug in and of course
it's not looking good at this point.
They're going to stand to at zero
four 30 which is pretty common.
Going to be up before the sunrise and you
want to be up before the enemy as well.
Hmm.
Now they get together and get some word.
Here we go back to the book.
It did not take long. He did not take
the colonel long to give us our orders.
The brigade was to renew its effort to
reach the bridge and bring relief to the
men still fighting there, so
pretty simple, straightforward goal
and
in order to achieve this goal,
they set up to do an attack on this
little section of woods where they think
there's a bunch of Germans in here.
We go back to the book.
The leading sections plunged
into the wood and disappeared.
There were no there at all.
The information from
brigade must've been wrong.
We had attacked and
taken an empty position.
Never was there such an anticlimax,
but never was an anticlimax.
More welcome.
Now we get a little visit up
on the front lines. Here we go.
Back to the book. As the small spare
figure stepped out of the first vehicle,
I realized that it was the first time I
had seen the brigadier commander since
we left England.
He was just the same as ever.
Relaxed and smiling.
Battle was nothing new to him.
He had been through the worst of the
desert war muddle in no way disconcerted
him, at least not outwardly. It's
interesting. He uses the term,
muddle it. He's talking about
the fog of war. This model,
when you don't really
know what's happening,
and he talks about how the veterans are
used to it in a co and and accustomed to
it and they can deal with it,
muddle in no way, disconcerted him,
at least not outwardly.
He seemed to anticipate it.
Understanding how judgment and
behavior was impaired by danger.
Wherever he went,
he inspired confidence with his gentle
eyes and friendly manner for regular
cavalry officer. His background was
unusual. He had come to his regimen,
not from Sandhurst but from Oxford with
a double first and fluency and a half a
dozen languages,
and I love this line right here.
He wore his learning light neat
lightly as he did his decorations,
meaning this guy is highly
educated and highly decorated,
but you don't even know it.
It was rare for soldiers to be aware of
officers more senior than the colonels
who commanded their battalions, but
every man in the brigade would recognize,
could recognize a name to brigadier.
The two visitors did not stay long,
but their appearance was a tonic for all.
It was a reminder that that there were
able men in charge even though the battle
was developing in a rather odd manner.
Okay.
Now as they,
as he continues in these situation,
back to the book,
suddenly my preoccupation,
my preoccupation with the
problems of others ceased.
There was a familiar wine overhead and
I found my self propelled into the half
dug a trench all but on top
of Galbraith and Robert,
the action had been reflex.
I knew that I had made no conscious
decision to jump as I lay there with my
second in commands and trenching tool,
carving into a ridge and my left buttock,
the mortar bomb burst about
eight feet to the right,
the scream of the shards
of jagged metal passing.
Just overhead flailed my years as earth
and stones spattered down on top of us.
The stench of high explosive
filled my filled the trench.
My face I found was pressed into the
course material of corporal Galbraith's
battle trousers.
Gingerly raising my head,
I peered over the low parapet at
the foot of the tree of a tree,
some 15 yards away, lay emotionless
heap, a green and khaki bundle,
which did not stir.
Okay.
Jumping out of the trench, I ran
across and turned over the limp body.
Okay.
The head fell back to show the open
staring eyes of Sergeant Hawks,
one of the seven platoon section
commanders, a bright young,
a NCO only just promoted who had been
with the battalion since the day it was
raised.
Okay.
He was another old friend.
At first I could see no sign of injury,
but then I noticed the small hole in
the back of hawks helmet and the thin
stream of blood streaking
the back of his neck.
Okay.
Lying by hugging side,
I seem to count seven explosions all just
a little further away than the first,
but still close enough
to smell the hot gases.
There was a short pause and then as if
it were not an afterthought and eighth
bomb struck the branches of the
tree just above us directing.
It's hot metal splinters
down to the trenches below.
Okay.
A half strangled it's cry of distress.
Brought my head up just in time to see
Corporal Pritchard clamber out of his
slit and rate your race across the,
towards the CRI has half a sack of
medical supplies marked with its red cross
dangling from his hand. The pause
lasted no more than a half a minute.
Again, the wine again, I ducked.
This was the covering fire
for a counter attack or the,
was this the covering fire for a counter
attack or where the Boesch merely
harassing us?
Spitefully
okay.
But when I raised my head from Higgins,
from Huggins boots to look around,
I was relieved to see one of
the seven platoon Bren gunners,
his helmet and i's just above the level
of the parapet gazing down the track
towards his front.
Okay.
So the centuries we're
still doing their job.
The fire was not forcing their heads down.
If there,
if this was the covering
fire for an attack,
we would not be caught unawares.
So that's the standard procedure right
here for the Germans and really for
anyone it's covered move, right? We
put in big bonds, we put in mortars,
we put her on in artillery
and while you're hiding and
while you're ducking down
so you don't get killed,
they maneuver it and then write it right.
When they get so close that they're
in danger of their own artillery,
the artillery stops and then they proceed
with the assault. Here we go. The low.
Now there is a law of the law
provided a chance to finish digging.
There was no longer any need to
persuade the pen to dig faster.
The lesson had really been driven home.
We'd been dating for no more than a few
minutes when the sound of firing to the
north slackened, but the noise from
the vehicles in front had increased.
The thought of guns only a few hundred
yards away was punctuated by the
hammering of brands. By the way,
brands, I don't think I've said this,
brands are sort of the uh, weapon,
a British machine gun versus the,
the span now,
which is,
which is the German machine guns and
they use the Brits and the Americans use
the term spanned out to talk
about basically heavy machine,
heavier machine guns.
But,
but that's what they're talking about
when you're talking about spend out.
And then a brand is the Brit machine gun.
Both Ford platoons were inaction and I
had placed company headquarters too far
back to be able to see what was happening.
The walkie talkies were silent,
also quite worried about the sitting
of the full tune, some 300 yards apart,
each isolated in its own corner of the
woods and unable to support the others
against a determined attack.
This is so important for
tactical leaders out there.
Think about these lessons and these are
lessons that I talk about all the time.
And these are lessons that I used
to have to teach all the time.
So you've got your platoons,
they're out there doing something.
You need to be close enough that
you have communications with them.
So that you actually
understands what's happening.
And this is the same
in the business world.
If you put yourself in a
position to where you can't,
well you don't understand
what's happening in the field,
then you're not going to be able to help.
You're not gonna be able to support,
you're not going to be able to,
to understand what's happening.
So you can make decisions.
Mm. So in this point,
he's positioned himself too far away.
On top of that,
he's positioned his platoons
too far apart from each other.
So if you're too far apart from each
other, you can't cover for each other.
If you can't cover, you can't move.
And if you can't move, you can't win.
So those are critical points.
Make sure your command
position is close enough,
not so close that you're
getting in the firefight. Note,
not so close that you're pinned down,
but close enough so that you
understand what is happening.
And then if you have multiple
elements in the field,
do you get them close enough to each
other that they can support each other?
Always.
He sees a guy running back and here we go.
Back to the book,
it was sergeant prior, one of Nesbitt
section commanders are rather sulky,
man able and well educated,
but with a grudge against authority.
And his left lefthand prior
grasp is sten in a grip.
So from that the knuckles showed
blue under the under the sunburn.
His right arm from which clothing had
been caught away at the shoulder was
thrust into the front of his smock. The
elbow covered by a blood stain dressing.
His face was white with
shock and taught with pain.
A morphine injection was doing little to
alleviate the agony of an elbow smashed
by a bullet.
Okay.
The news prior brought was serious.
The vehicles which we could here we're
Boesch armor driving backwards and
forward along the road and sweeping the
front of nine paltunes position secure
from retaliation. So far, the
armor head only claimed prior,
but sergeant Avondale had been killed
by a mortar fragment as he dashed across
between a couple of trees to
put some question to Nesbitt.
This inexhaustible loss of skilled
leaders was serious in our parachute
battalions on like usual infantry units,
section leaders ranked as sergeants,
not corporals.
Nine platoon had now lost,
not only it's officer,
but three of its four sergeants as well.
Hawks was dead and one of seven platoon
section commanders had failed to appear
at the rendezvous after the drop already
nearly half the sergeants had become
casualties.
This is just a nightmare unfolding.
Hm.
Back to the book. After we'd put the
final touches on our slit trenches,
time was found a scrape,
a shallow grave for sergeant hawks.
It was hard to suppress one's revulsion
at touching the body of someone I had
known so well, but just as I
was stealing myself to do so.
Huggin step forward,
ripped open the dead man's smock and
shirt and slipped one of the two identity
disks over the blood stained head,
the sergeant major then unbuckled his
watch and search the pockets for anything
which might be useful.
A Morpheus syringe and a field dressing,
a bar of chocolate and a couple of mills
grenades, two packets of cigarettes,
and a box of matches.
A couple of maps and a pocket knife.
There was nothing personal except for a
grubby on envelope containing a half a
dozen faded in dog geared snapshots of
the stout smiling girl holding a baby.
Okay.
Before buttoning the envelope
into his breast pocket,
hugging slipped the identity
disc between the photographs
I was helping Corporal Pritchard
shoveled the earth back over hawks body,
listening with one ear to hug and sharing
the dead man's ammunition and other
possessions among the members
of the company headquarters.
When suddenly I became aware of
Jimmy Gray standing beside me,
apparently h just to speak,
but diff diffident at interrupting,
telling Pritchard to finish the job.
I rose from my knees.
Glad to be able to put my
mind to something else.
When I turned to speak to gray,
I was disturbed by what I saw.
The dirt of battle had
exaggerated his usual scruffiness.
Okay.
As smart controllers were coated with
mud and dust and his right sleeve was
stained from top to bottom with blood,
not his own.
As he explained when he
saw my eyes fixed on it,
the front of his smock and the battle
dress under neath had been torn by a large
fragment of a mortar bomb,
which in some miraculous fashion had
failed to even scratch him three inches to
one side and it would have been set
and it would have severed his head,
but it was the eyes above
the pallet on shaven cheeks,
which were frightening.
Okay?
They were empty of life when he spoke.
The words are lucid and well chosen has
ever, but the voice lacked expression.
The phrases were cold.
It was not as if you were describing
events which he had himself witnessed,
but something unreal,
something half imagined.
B Company at attacked at
zero 800 hours at the start,
they're advanced through the woods had
gone like the first attack of the morning,
a calm and steady progress against
the seemingly nonexistent enemy.
Then some hundred yards
short of the objective,
a swath the fire had cut down the
men of the two leading platoons,
the half grown trees and the
sparse undergrowth had neater,
neither hidden them nor shielded them
from the interlocking arcs of the enemy
weapons,
which covered every inch of ground.
It was just possible that they might
have been able to deal with the machine
guns alone,
but the armor was too much for them.
Pumping shells into the men
at near point blank range
gray had seen it all happen.
Okay.
The colonel had tried to stop the attack
as soon as the full strength of the
enemy position had become clear,
but by then more than half of the men
of the two leading platoons had been
killed or wounded.
Both sub alternates were dead.
The other officers and the
CSM at all been wounded.
The colonel had tried to turn the German
flanked by sending a company around to
the left,
but there was no flank.
Okay.
The second attack had been a replica
of the first. It too had collapsed,
but not before some 40 more
men were dead or maimed,
including two of the
four surviving officers.
Okay.
Harry Bates had been terribly wounded
in the stomach and by now was probably
dead.
That's great at pulled him behind
some cover his blood soaked to sleeve.
This was not the complete story.
There was further bad news.
Not only had our own
attack been shattered,
but the other battalion to our north
had hits similar enemy positions and was
making little progress progress in its
efforts to get into our Nemo along the
main road
from somewhere or other.
The bullshit found enough troops of
quality good enough to smash the brigades,
attempt to reach the city,
so we just have a horrible
situation unfolding.
Okay.
Back to the book from far away in the
distance came the drum of powerful
airplane engines.
Nesbitt was the first to spot the minute
shapes first circling and then diving
out of the sun towards us.
The noise changing to a shriek as the
machine swept down towards the wood,
towards the woods from a half a
dozen different directions. Uh,
happy shout of Spitfires rose from the
trenches at lasts some help but arrived
from the outside world.
The RAF had arrived to give us
close air support and that's,
you know, we've had close air support
save the day many times in, in,
in books that we've talked
about on this podcast.
As I gaved up at the doesn't
spit screaming down to
strafe the Boesch positions
on the sloping Ridge head.
Nesbitt's voice suddenly roared in my
year shouting to everyone to get their
heads down and hide their
faces as I duct with the rest.
I spotted the black crosses on the wings.
The aircraft were not ours,
but German measure Schmitz.
Our air superiority was so overwhelming
that it never occurred to anyone that
the machines might be hostile.
They were not diving onto the
enemy positions, but onto our own.
I gazed skywards the measure Schmidt
was so close that I could see the pilots
face.
Two rockets detach themselves from the
wings and swooped down to explode seconds
later in the woods where the
survivors of a and B companies,
we're settling into their new positions.
As I ducked once more,
there was another scream of engines from
behind followed by the sound of a storm
of bullet striking branches on the trees
and the other side two aircraft which
had discharge their rockets.
We're now carrying out a second run
strafing with their machine guns.
As I squeezed even closer to the earth
at the bottom of this shallow trench,
the reverberations of an explosion,
some 50 yards ways pounded my year drums.
It was another rocket.
Suddenly it ended the aircraft advantaged
as quickly as they had arrived.
Wow. Yeah. Cause at this point the, the,
the British and the Americans had almost
total air domination and so everyone
just completely assumed that,
oh thank God here comes some
spitfires to come and save us.
And and they were wrong.
Now the the air,
we did have air domination for the most
part and one of the things that they
needed as you,
as you heard these airborne troops,
they can only carry so much and
so they're, they're going to need,
they need more ammunitions. They
need medical gear, they need food,
they need water.
They need stuff to be dropped to them,
and so there was a plan in place for
them to have gear and food and equipment
and ammunition dropped to them at these
locations where they were supposed to
be, because remember they were supposed
to be making progress this whole time.
They're not making progress,
but there are supposed to
be making progress and since
communication is so bad,
they can't call back and say,
hey, we're not. We're supposed
to be, we're over here.
Drop the gear on us.
But the gear gets dropped in
the pre planned positions,
which of course our enemy positions,
but here's what it sounds like for them,
or here's what they're thinking on
the ground. Then to the south of us,
I saw the familiar shape of a line of
Dakotas approaching at about a thousand
feet in a minute.
The Sky was crammed with them.
It was the first supply drop about which
we had been told that the briefings,
but the drop zone was a couple miles
away over the other side of the hill.
Right in the middle of enemy positions.
Yeah.
By now, of course the division
should have captured the area,
but the Boesch still held it.
News of the progress of the battle could
not have reached the RAF or the pilots
would have diverted a drop
their supplies elsewhere.
Now they can see this happening
and the people that are in the plains,
they're called the RASC,
the Royal Army Service Corps.
They run basically the
supply and the logistics and,
and help resupply and drop this equipment.
So this is,
he's as he's watching all these Dakota's
the Dakotas are these little transport
plans.
It's actually what they had parachuted
out of and now they're watching them drop
this resupply
back to the book among the mass.
A Single Dakota just
overhead caught my attention.
Okay.
It had already been hit and flames were
creeping down from the starboard engine
toward the cockpit.
Yeah.
As it lost height, the khaki clad Ra. See,
dispatchers were standing at the
open doorway pushing out the penny,
heirs of supplies.
Those are the bags of supplies.
Okay.
I could see their faces.
The fire was on their side of the plane.
The wing was burning before their eyes.
The Dakota was now little more
than 300 feet above the ground.
If the men at the door jumped.
Now they might just save
themselves in a second or two more.
The aircraft would be so low that their
parachutes would not have time to open
this.
The men must have known,
but they went on with their routine drill,
pushing out the panty heirs regardless
of what would happen to them.
Then the starboard wing crumpled.
The flaming plane
disappeared behind the trees.
The panty are still
falling from the open door.
The Sky was empty.
The last plane had gone
cool,
but we still stood. Watching the
place where the Dakota had vanished.
Mourning the futility of the self
sacrifice we had just witnessed.
Right.
Can't even imagine that
guys just continuing to do their job
knowing their fate
at
there. Their senior officers at this
point, and they're in CEO's are,
are starting to get hit pretty regular
beach by snipers and so he decides to,
he tells his his guys,
Hey,
take your take your rank off your uniform
because I don't want the enemy to know.
And he tells us to one of his,
one of his leaders name
named Robert and he says,
I watched Robert's slip,
his captain stars off his shoulders
and tucked them away in his pocket.
I knew for certain that my second in
command disapproved officers should show
themselves as such. So one
of his guys is thinking, no,
we're officers. We need to, we need
to stand out. We need to stand up.
Now
I mentioned the American forces,
the 82nd and the hundred and
first and the British forces.
There was also a Polish parachute brigade
that was coming in on this attack as
well and they were scheduled to come in
a little bit later as reinforcements.
And here we go back to
the back whole book.
Only then did I remember that the
glider born part of the Polish parachute
brigade was due to land that afternoon
upon the stretch of enemy upon the
stretch of open country below us.
At the same time as the parachute
battalions were dropped in the polder land
south of our Nem bridges,
the landing zone was already a battlefield
and the wretched polls we're about to
land in the middle of it.
First the gliders hit the ground.
It's massive weight tearing up chunks
of stubble as it skidded to a halt
lurching onto one wing.
As it did so,
men jumped out and rushed to the rear
end to release the tail unit so that the
vehicles inside could be driven out to
more gliders were not plowing across the
ground.
Another exploded in the air and a vast
ball of yellow flame just as it was upon
the point of touching down,
mortar bombs were bursting among the
men struggling to release their loads.
While streams of chase tracer bisected
the scene into oddly formal patterns,
another glider was on fire on the
ground as still more swooped in to land,
adding to the chaos. The polls were
now joining in the battle themselves,
some firing toward the Germans,
some towards the Kpos B,
which is the king's own Scottish borders.
It's a,
it's another British unit and some in
the direction of our other battalion.
It must be impossible for the Poles
to distinguish enemy from friend.
They probably thought they had
landed in a circle of Boesch units,
all intent upon their destruction.
In a few minutes,
it was all over from the
wrecked and flaming gliders,
which now littered the ground.
Small parties of Poles were making their
escape firing at anything they saw move.
Two or three vehicles had been
driven away, but otherwise
they'd failed the drag,
their jeeps and guns from the gliders.
The Polish anti tank battery no
longer existed as a fighting unit.
It had landed in the middle of a battle
and been destroyed before it could fire
a single shot waste. It
was waste. Once again.
Waste like the supply drop.
Nothing seemed to go right.
Uh, not have some eight
polls charged towards us.
Intent on seeking shelter either in the
woods or behind the safety of a railway
embankment,
some 30 yards away.
One man slightly ahead of the others
must have noticed our camouflage steel
helmets in the slit trenches
ahead and shouted a warning
in a bunch.
They flung themselves into the undergrowth
anticipating what would happen.
I yelled to everyone to get their heads
down just as a hail of bullets from the
Poles whistled over our heads,
a few hitting the trench pair of pits,
but most striking the trees well above
our heads as the excited men empty their
weapons in our direction.
So long as we kept our heads down,
we were safe from the Polish fire.
But the worry was that some of them
might creep closer and start to fling
grenades around. However,
in a couple of minutes,
the firing slackened and then ceased
possibly the polls sense that something
might be wrong when no one retaliated.
The comparative silence provided the
opportunity to shout a warning across the
narrow stretch of ground
which separated us.
There was no reply and I shouted
once again and faltering English,
a voice inquired who we were
firmly.
The company sergeant major Huggins told
them, the polls seem to understand.
After a few seconds of
audible consultation,
they rose to their feet and walked across.
So you've got to be just a
chaotic situation. The polls land,
they're getting attacked from
all directions and sure enough,
they're shooting at the friendly forces
blue on blue happening once he gets them
settled down,
he's got some people,
some of these Polish folks that now
have no leadership. Back to the book,
calling Douglas over.
I told him that he now had a fourth
section in seven platoon and within a few
minutes the polls were digging hard
under the tutelage of their corporal.
The only comprehensible part of
whose name sounded like Peter.
The digging had hardly started.
When a jeep roared down the track and
the direction from the direction of the
battalion headquarters as it breaked
to stop and the cover of the trees,
Jimmy get gray,
jumped out and ran towards us.
Gray's news was startling.
We were all to withdraw to
Wolf Hasan in 15 minutes time.
One could not just stand up
and walk away from an enemy,
right on one's heels in day light.
The only way to withdraw was to move
by bounds with platoons and companies
covering one another back.
Any other plan was madness.
Things over in the north must be bad
and deed for the colonel to be rushed in
this way.
But Grey's instructions were unshakeable.
So they're digging in and are
getting ordered. Get out of here,
we're going to leave. And he saying,
okay, that's fine, but guess what?
Even when you leave and you still use
the fundamental principle of cover and
move. Yeah, and that's
what he's wanting to do.
So now they're on the retreat
and here we go. Back to the book.
The pace was far too quick.
Some men were all but running to keep up.
As I had expected, a little by little
cohesion, we're starting to break down.
Some of the men of the mortar platoon had
overtaken us despite the weight of the
loads and we're mixed in among us.
There were two small groups from another
unit in the middle of seven platoon
from somewhere in the front, a
long way off. A Spandau spent sent,
it's bullets flying harmlessly overhead,
but men were looking
apprehensive and flinching.
We were now under fire from two
different directions. At any minute.
The Bush would find the range and
then the slaughter would begin.
It was no longer an orderly retreat.
The withdrawal was taking on the nature
of a hoard of men seeking safety.
Soon discipline would crack and
everyone would start to run.
What a target.
We must be some 500 men from four to
five different units rapidly coalescing
into a solid moving mass.
Yeah.
This is just a nightmare
and you can imagine it's an
individual thing and you're
going to see some great
leadership examples,
but it's an individual thing because if
you can keep the teams working together,
covering and moving for each other,
that's good.
You're going to keep
the enemies heads down.
But if w if people in the group
starts saying, you know what,
I'm not going to cover.
I'm going to run. Yeah,
and now no one's covering and now you've
got a bunch of people that are moving
and no cover and that's when
you're going to get slaughtered.
Not only going to get slaughtered by
by people that are shooting at you,
but if you're not putting down cover fire,
the enemy maneuvers,
they don't just sit there.
I mean some of them we shooting,
but there'll be shooting,
but other elements of them are going to
move and they're going to be able to cut
you off.
They finally do make it back and they get
it. They get a little bit of luck here.
Here we go. Back to the book, we
caught our breath in the wood so they,
they get to a woods.
David's men had disappeared and there
was no sign of the kernel or of the
battalion headquarters. No one had
followed us. We the last across,
but a quick check told me
that only Robert Watson,
the CSM and three or four other men were
missing in addition to seven bill toone
of the ladder.
There was nothing to be seen in all.
There were still about 50 men with me.
Not Counting Peter and his seven poles
still clinging tenaciously to us.
Perhaps I should try to get back across
the bullet spattered embankment to find
out what had happened to the others.
But the noise of the
battle was getting louder.
The Boesch must be closing in the vital
thing must be to rejoin the rest of the
battalion with the 50 men I still
had and not to leave them in loop.
Tyler's charge while I returned on
what could be a foolhardy errand,
but it was difficult to avoid the
thought that perhaps I was reluctant,
reluctant to climb back over
the top of that embankment.
So he,
he does make it to this woods,
but he didn't have everybody with
him and he's questioning himself,
should I go back over
there and risk it or not?
And part of is part of his
rationalizing, you know, I,
the best thing to do is get back
with the rest of the Italian.
But part of him is saying,
you're rationalizing this and you're just,
you're just not, you're, you're
being a coward. But he does. He,
he proceeds on with Italian.
He knows he's going to get killed.
If he goes over that, he can hear the
enemy coming. So back to the book,
10 minutes later, we found the remnants
of the battalion, half of a company,
the mortars and what was left of the
machine guns were still were missing as
well as our own seven platoon.
More than one third of the men who had
withdrawn from the woods had failed
across the railway. We were now down to
no more than a couple of hundred men.
Okay,
so we're going,
we're down to a couple of hundred men
from five or 600 men in the battalion,
maybe even a little bit more,
maybe there might have been
700 men in the battalion.
They get word once again.
Here's what's going to happen
tomorrow at first light,
the brigade would move on to booster
beak to join the rest of the division,
but unless ammunition together with air
and artillery support was forthcoming,
the prospects were far from good.
We were,
it seemed not opposed by
a few third line troops.
Elements of three SS Panzer divisions
had been identified in the battle.
The Germans seemed to have moved quickly
or else something had gone wrong with
the intelligence.
It was not surprising that the days
fighting had been so very bitter,
so they're pointing out that they
weren't going against, you know,
third rate troops. They were going
up against ss Panzer divisions,
the best of the German soldiers.
In talking with
sergeant major bower and Sergeant Nesbitt,
before I reached Tyler's platoon,
I had done my best to be
as cheerful as possible,
but it was plain that the two [inaudible]
realized that I was making the best of
things. With Luke Tyler. It was different.
I could not insult him by trying
to disguise our straights.
I just told them the facts as I
had received them from the kernel.
Possibly it was a mistake.
Quite suddenly,
the failure of it all oppressed me.
In less than 36 hours,
two thirds of the battalion had gone,
15 rifle company officers had landed.
Only two were left.
10 for certain had either
been killed or wounded.
The chances of surviving another day.
We're small fatigue and a hunger.
It drained me.
There was a need to unburden myself.
Luke was junior in my rank, but
equal in years. And in any case,
it was easier to confide in someone
who was, in many ways a stranger.
Even as I spoke,
I was ashamed of this weakness,
but there was no stopping quietly.
Luke gave me the reassurance I needed the
iron needed to sustain oneself through
such a day was easily expended.
And I felt that I had
purloined some of Luke share.
So he, he basically on loads to one
of his guys or to want to another, uh,
another officer below him in rank. But
what I think is interesting about this is
he needed someone to talk to.
He knew he was holding it all inside
and wasn't saying anything and trying to
look positive. And even he's looking
at his guys as he's telling them,
don't worry gents, we're going to be okay.
And his guys are looking at him like,
Hey, no, we don't believe
you. And so he has to,
he feels the need to unload on
someone. And that's why, you know,
I just think from my perspective,
you know,
we always talk about relationships that
you have on your team and for sure in
your platoon or in your team,
it's really good to have someone that
you can just kind of unload on that,
you know,
is professional enough to bolster you up
without getting dragged down into your
negativity.
And a lot of times I've found if,
if you have someone like that,
or maybe a couple people like that
and your team that you can talk to,
well guess what?
Sometimes they're going to be bolstering
your attitude and sometimes you're
going to be bolstering their attitude.
And so you gotta,
you gotta find someone like that that's
in your team that you can say, man,
this is, this is horrible,
this is going wrong. And that
someone's going to go, hey,
you know what? It's not that bad. We're
going to get through it. And then through,
or three days later, he might
become to you and saying, Hey,
this is a horrible situation that I can't
believe this. And you're going to say,
no man, we're going to be all right. So
I think it's important and that's again,
we're building relationships,
but that's one of the reasons
we build relationships.
They get into a holdup position.
Back to the book on stand two rounds,
I found the Polish trenches
empty except for Peter there.
Corporal crouched grimly behind his brand,
the rest of the party advantaged in the
early hours sensing perhaps a day at
attach themselves to an unlucky unit.
Peter explained nothing
but as embarrassment.
It was clear it was both unfair and
pointless to press him for details when
either pride or sense of duty had kept
him there to fight among strangers.
The fault of what would have happened if
the enemy at attack from this direction
against the position held by
one solitary man was chilling.
It was a mistake to trust strangers
I had learned yet another lesson.
Rely on only those you knew.
Again, it's interesting how he sometimes
backs off. Instead of pressing w,
where are your guys? He knows, he's
like, what? What point is that?
Or when Bartholomew was,
was running away,
he didn't press him super hard and
you're going to get to a point,
there's pointing to here
when he does press people,
but here he's decided
he's not going to do it.
And the other interesting thing is here
it says, I learned another lesson rely,
you know, not distrust
strangers relying on only those,
you know what you have to do in those
situations is you have to put someone that
you do trust in bed them with
these units that you don't know.
So if you would have taken,
and he gave these,
he gave that section to one of his
platoon commanders and said, hey,
you got another section now,
but maybe in bed one more guy or two
more guys in there or split these guys up
even more. So instead of seven and one
big bulk, you put two or three there,
two or three,
there are two or three there and now you
split them up a little bit and you can
have better control over them.
Yeah, it's weird. There's, you know,
there's opportunity to dessert though.
And these guys took the opportunity. Sure.
Now the fighting rages on and obviously
I have to fast forward through some of
it and they eventually get
into of little village,
a little small village and they've,
they've taken down,
they've taken some buildings and here we
go there in these buildings back to the
book, we were in a mess. The Boesch
were on the other side of the valley,
outnumbered and outgunned us.
Okay.
There was not the slightest
hope of reaching the back
of the breed line this way
and to stay here on this Ford
slope was impossible at this rate,
we would all be dead or wounded soon.
Okay?
Somehow I had to get the survivors
back up the hill, but it was near,
but it was a near in Superbowl problem
with the men scattered down among the
houses, lawns and shrubberies
shot at every time they moved.
Someone called from the side of the house.
As I turned and looked private,
Gregory darted across to throw himself
down beside me under the dirt and two
days scrub of beard.
His face was grayish white.
He seemed about to vomit
as Gregory stammered out his platoon
commanders. I knew what had happened.
Lieutenant Tyler was dead.
It must have happened
just after we parted.
Luke had been killed on
the steep garden path,
which led from the house down the
road. He'd, he'd been hit by a sniper,
killed outright by a
bullet through the heart.
We did a couple of yards of the
place where Gregory was lying.
Possibly Luke had been careless
because he was still dazed,
but he had to get back to his platoon
and the path was his only route.
So they had been together and they'd been
hit by a some kind of artillery in the
house and it rattled them.
And then Luke had gone out to get back
back to his platoon and when he left,
he got shot by a sniper back to the book.
This was how officers and ntls were
killed just doing their routine job.
This was why casualties among the leaders
were so high all the time that they
were moving about checking here,
encouraging their backwards and forwards.
Now besides myself and
only the quartermaster,
sergeant bower and
Sergeant Weiner were left,
all the rest of the officers and
sergeants and the company had gone.
One problem,
however,
had been solved the remnants of Tyler's
to forward sections had mannered,
managed to extricate themselves
without waiting for orders.
Since last night,
private Gregory had been in charge
of one of the other sections,
both the ncls having been hit the day
before during that last mortar stock,
a bomb and fallen right on top of the
corporal who's commanding the other
section, blowing him and his
brand gunner half to pieces.
Commonsense had told us survivors to quit
and there had been no one to stop them
except Gregory,
who for the moment was shaken by the
sight of what had happened to his friends
and who in any case lack the
authority to hold them there.
No one else had been hit and scrambled
back and the survivors were now
sheltering in the house.
Okay,
so they're in these houses and,
and for the first time you're going
to hear the company commander start to
realize he's got people at the
breaking point. Back to the book.
The others were as uneasy
as I was for the first time.
I was unhappy about them until now.
They'd endured the success of disasters,
but the events of the morning
had tried them too far.
It had been yesterday, once
again, yet another failure,
failure against an enemy who
is far too strong for us.
Men we're looking jittery. Some could
be well near their breaking point.
As I gazed down the slope, trying to
spot some activity among the Bush,
a movement to the right caught
my eye about 20 yards away.
Two of Kelly's men were
moving diagonally behind me,
sheltered the far side of the ridge.
Okay,
these are, these are desert, hers.
My shout made them hesitate and then
stop after two or three more steps for
getting the enemy,
I stood up and strode down towards them.
No explanation was necessary.
The surly guilt on their faces was enough.
Deliberately choosing words for effect.
I cursed them in language,
rarely used by officers
towards their soldiers.
Okay.
It was enough. The two men turned
back towards their platoon.
Okay.
So like I said, sometimes he or if
they're there, he's dropping the hammer.
These two guys are trying to dessert and
he goes on and drops the hammer on them
and gets them back with their platoon.
Back to the book. In this mood,
the men would never stand
up to an enemy attack.
Even a mortar stock could break them.
I could see it happening.
First one or two men would slip away like
the two I had just stopped and then a
rush would follow.
Something drastic had to be done.
No more than the occasional rifle
bullet was now coming over. In fact,
no one had been hit since we took
our positions along this rich,
it seems safe enough standing up.
I began to walk along the path
towards the left of our position.
For the first few steps.
I felt wretchedly vulnerable,
but then an odd exoration seized me
for the first few steps.
I felt wretchedly vulnerable,
but then an odd exhilaration seized
me not too slowly and not too quickly.
I strode deliberately toward the first
group of men grinning down at Lance
Corporal Williams.
I made some inept remark about it being
the wrong place for a company. Clark,
if I were to be hit,
it would happen anyway.
Now seem to be as good a time as
ever stopping at each group of men.
I checked their firing positions and
made necessary changes that I was at the
end of Kelly's line and I started back
conscious that everyone was watching.
There was a burst of machine gun fire,
well wide of us,
but I managed to avoid flinching at it.
Suddenly,
sergeant we whiners
voice harsh with concern,
was yelling at me to get down demanding
angrily what I was playing at the spell
broke. I was grateful for the excuse
to lower myself down beside him,
very relieved that it was over
the rage and winders face
dissolved into an on a custom grin.
The corny dramatics were over,
but they had served their purpose.
The men had got a grip on themselves.
So he basically stood
up and walked around and
talked to everyone and made himself
visible and made himself appear to not be
scared to get the guys heads back in the
day until his sergeant winder yells at
him and says, hey dude, get down when
these guys, these are like the desert is,
where did they go so they
can head back towards,
towards the areas that had been secured.
So as this beach edge, you know,
we landed d day,
June 6th this is now in September.
So you know,
coalition forces or or sorry,
allied forces had pushed into France.
So if you could walk back,
you could eventually get too
friendly lines. Yeah. And that's,
that's what their plan was.
And then what that when you get there,
don't they know, hey you do 30 days, you'd
say, all right. You know, you'd say, Oh,
I was, I got separated from
my chops when I parachuted in.
I couldn't find my people or whatever.
You make up your lie and you deal with
it later with it later because right now
you're thinking I'm not going to make it
the crazy,
it was clear why nothing.
We had heard nothing from battalion
headquarters for the past two hours.
Like everyone else,
the signal,
the signalers orderlies and clerks had
been fighting for their own survival.
The Germans were all around them and had
been pressing them hard throughout the
morning so they're not getting any
information about what's happening.
This is, this is interesting.
He goes back to get they,
they ended up with a little extra
ammunition and he goes back to get some
ammunition from the battalion.
They haven't got it like stage in the
battalion headquarters and and how's he's
doing this?
He is,
the ammunition was in a jeep
and so he goes to the jeep,
he finds the jeep and he's with one of
his other guys and they're the regimental
sergeant major is sitting basically on
top of the jeep on top of the ammunition
and he kind of is looking at
the guy, you know, saying,
Hey, I'm here. I'm an all
star. I got paltunes out
there and a company out there,
I got to get them ammunition
and he doesn't really move.
He just kind of sits
there. Hmm. And so finally,
uh,
here he was here,
the regimental Sergeant Major was in
the middle of battle sitting on his arse
and taking his ease while a company
commander hunted for ammunition majors are
not in the habit of rebuking regimental
sergeant majors, but this was too much.
The tensions of the morning.
It's snapped myself for spray restraint.
And in a couple of succinct sentences,
I told the RS,
the regimental sergeant
major what I thought of him.
Okay.
Then the row,
the regimental sergeant major apologized,
but he did not move without any trace
of irony or annoyance in his voice.
He quietly explained that he could not
stand up because he had been shot through
both legs.
I had not noticed the airborne smock
with which someone had covered his
outstretched and bandaged legs.
Thanks.
I think
before you act
now they're on their way. They're
heading finally to this area of Ooh,
stir beak there on their patrol.
And here we go.
Back to the book of Spandau opening
up ahead, sent us all to the ground.
Men diving for cover just a little
too quickly on a moment later,
a second gun fired on us from the right,
but it was the,
it was the ominous rattle
of the tracked vehicles,
which chilled the first one than another.
Then two more quite close and in front.
Their engine clatter rising above the
din of the machine, guns and rifles.
Then some 70 yards away.
I saw the first of the SP guns.
It's stubby weapon traversing slowly
towards us. Sp guns are there.
They're kind of like tanks.
It's, it's self propelled guns.
They're like artillery
pieces with tracks on them.
The flash from its stout from it's now,
it was one of,
with the explosion of the bursting shell,
just to the right,
a half grown tree shattered
in a jagged splinters,
a second shot following hard on the first
one covered Harrison and me with earth.
We were swamped by the noise.
Every sort of weapons seemed to be firing.
Grenades were exploding,
but the distinct above the rest was
the clank and the throaty cough of the
armored guns caught
like this and the open.
We were helpless tanks plowing among
about among us could have been no worse.
There was no way of fighting back.
No one does seem to have even a PR which
is like their Bazooka anti armor weapon
and we could not get close
enough to use the gammon bombs.
The bags of plastic explosive carried
for the for use against armor,
so that's another little,
it's like a big
bag of explosives that you can put on a,
on a armored vehicle to destroy it.
They call them gammon bombs. The
men in front, we're moving again.
I stood up and signaled those behind
to follow. We were doubling now,
but there was still some sort of control.
We were not running away but making
for somewhere where I did not know.
Then about a hundred yards away,
I caught a glimpse through the
trees have a German half track.
It stopped and helmeted
shapes jump from its sides.
How many more of them were there?
This could be the start of another attack,
which could only end it all our will
to fight back was all but broken.
Then I heard the Brig,
the brigadier telling me to clear the
enemy out of the hollow after which the
survivors of the brigade
would join us there c company,
it seemed was the last
organized body of troops,
so they're looking at this area,
this open area where there's some enemy,
but it looks like it's a good position.
Of course,
their will to fight is just about broken
and you hear the brigadier is saying,
Hey, take your company and
clear out that hollow. Go
back to the book for a moment.
I was so dumbfounded that I hardly heard
the brigadier going on to say that the
brigade major was dead as well.
Killed about five minutes ago.
Another friend was gone,
but I hardly listened.
What was the brigadier ordering us to
do and his quiet and determined fashion.
It was absurd. The men were
finished. Only a few minutes ago,
I had realized that they were
passed defending themselves.
Now we were being told to
assault that Boesch position.
The brigadiers look was both
quizzical and encouraging.
The confounded man could see
what was passing through my mind.
Then I was away dodging back and through
the bushes towards the men in the ditch.
Even more aware than ever before of the
bullets singing overhead with my back to
a broad tree which hit
me from the enemy front.
I looked down at the upturn faces.
There was no point in wasting at
all in wasting time on details.
The orders I had to give them more,
quite simple,
devoid of any complications such
as who would provide covering fire.
It was time for play,
acting again,
my naturally loud voice carrying down
the line of men and Bung above the sound
of battles.
I balled them to follow me.
Adding the comment that is better to be
killed going for the basters than lying
in that bloody ditch.
No one has a stated.
The men rose to their feet.
At the moment,
I stepped out into the open from
behind the shelter of the tree.
Glancing to my right. I was exhilarated
by the sight of David Unwin.
Solid bulk running parallel to me and
half a dozen of his men following David
shouted something to the effect
that they were coming as well.
And I waved my sten gone and
acknowledgement behind me.
Sergeant Winder broke into a
scream of rage, harsh and furious.
The yell spread down the line too
heavily laden and too tired to sprint.
We lumbered forward towards the
enemy and a sort of jog trot.
Now, I was careless of everything.
We did not stand a chance,
but this was the right way to go.
This was the proper way to finish it all.
Nearly hysterical.
Now with rage and excitement, I heard
my own voice join in the screaming.
The Germans were shooting at us.
I could see flashes of their weapons
springing out of the gloom of the trees.
There was no need to look back to
confirm that the line of men was still
following the noise
told me they were there.
Now the boats were no
more than 50 yards away.
As I brought my sten down to hip level,
depress the trigger.
They flashed through my mind that it was
the first time I had fired my weapon.
Since the battle started my
four fingers squeeze the metal,
nothing happened.
It had jammed.
Here I was running toward the enemy with
a useless piece of metal in my hands.
Yeah.
There were figures moving among the trees.
First,
a couple than a half dozen dark
shapes were outlined against the green
background. Men sprinting away,
men disappearing through the trees.
The boats were running away.
We had done it.
We had driven the enemy out at the point
of bay and that this was the ultimate
in war.
The site of the savage screaming
parachute is streaming towards them,
had been too much for the Germans,
even though they had to do nothing
more than keep their heads and shoot
straight.
Yeah. So there you go. Surrounded, broken.
And I think the key point here,
okay.
When you're think you're
broken, do something and do
something aggressive. Yeah.
That's, that's The d. This is, this is
a hundred percent default aggressive.
That's what this is. You know what?
We're here. We're being defensive.
We're hiding in our slit trenches.
Okay. You know what we're going to do?
We're going to attack. We're
going to attack full force. Yeah.
Back to the book. The sight of David
on the right added to my delight,
shouting to him to hold
the right of the hollow.
I directed Sergeant
Weiner round to the left.
There was no need to tell anyone to hurry.
They all knew that the Germans would
not delay in mounting a counter attack.
Umone of terror distracted me.
I turned to the wounded German.
The man's features were contorted
into a rictus of despair.
Above him stood sergeant major Kelly red
eyed and panting his band that raised
above the soldiers stomach,
but Kelly did not strike.
He was relishing the moment snatching
maximum pleasure from the wounded man's
anguish before he sliced it
sliced into the soft belly.
As my newly found mouser
knocked the bayonet to one side,
the sergeant major smelled at me in an
unspoken protest at such silly scruples.
Then he seemed to shake himself.
The blood lust has bad past did.
He came to his senses,
gathering his men to the
defenses. So again, he could,
this guy goes from the pure fury
and rage of this incredible bayonet,
all salt,
and then he immediately just puts his
one of his sergeant majors in check who's
about to, you know, rent
ruthlessly killed this wounded guy.
Very interesting dichotomy there.
Mm hmm.
Back to the book. Something
had been snatched back from
the disasters of the day.
The remnants of the brigade headquarters
together with a few stragglers from
other units had now all arrived in all,
there seemed to be about 150 men with
a half a dozen officers as well as the
Brigadier David and myself.
There was Jimmy Gray.
The latter brought news that
the colonel was probably dead,
although he could not be sure as they'd
become separated during a scrimmage with
an sp gun of the rest of the officers
who had jumped with a battalion captain
John Simmons.
The gunner forward observer
was the only left one left.
Okay.
Continuing.
After about 15 minutes,
a lowland shooting suggested that I might
now be able to get round to visit the
battalion positions.
The battalion for the first time,
it struck me that I was now in command
of what was left of it, pitiful remnants,
but they are still fighting.
The brigadier had allotted the south
and west sides of the perimeter to us.
The first pit held sergeant wiener
with seven or eight men at the bottom.
His eyes shut,
lay a gray faced and motionless private
Gregory shot through his stomach.
Okay.
Corporal Pritchard had bandaged him
up and give them a shot of Morphia,
but because his airborne smock had
been pulled down over his blood stain
dressing to keep as warm as possible,
he laid there with no outward sign of
injury looking as a man might do who had
collapsed with exhaustion.
Gregory's eyes opened when he
saw who was standing over him.
He asked for the favor.
His voice was quiet.
His words measured in coherent.
His proposal quite logical out here.
Without the help of a doctor,
he was going to die in any case and
he could stand the pain no longer
which someone please put
a bullet through his head.
For the moment my grip tightened
on the Mauser and Gregory State,
I probably would have been
asking for the same release.
If it did happen, I hope that someone
would have the guts to give it to me.
Then I caught whiners.
I then he knew that I could not do it.
The only way to help Gregory was to
give him a further shot of more for Ya.
Dangerous though it would be to do so.
As I reached for my own ampule
in the breast pocket of my smock,
I was ashamed by my reluctance.
The reason it was purely selfish,
sooner or later I might
want to use it on myself.
Wounded and alone behind a bush
with no one about to help me.
But Sergeant Wiener came to the rescue.
He had scrounged a couple of supply of
ampules from somewhere or another opening
the small black tin. He Bared Gregory's
arm and pressed the needle home.
The words of sympathy and encouragement
sounded pitifully trite as I pressed
Gregory's shoulder,
nervous of any reproach,
which I might see.
I turned and walked away without
looking at the wound and man's face.
My name was being called.
It was private Jones slithering towards
me down the opposite slope of the hollow.
Jones told me quickly,
I was major Unwin killed by a sniper
shot through the forehead as he,
he's peering over the rim of the hollow,
trying to locate the whereabouts
of a span dough machine gun.
He died instantly. Jones was adamant.
There was no doubt that he was dead.
His brains had been blown out.
Jones was urging me to come see his body,
but I could not bring myself to do so.
David could not be dead.
They could not have killed David.
Everyone else, yes, one after
another, friends had died,
but I never believed that this
could happen in David. So vast,
so indestructable the humerus,
gentle David.
The brigadier was beside me.
He had also heard the
news for nearly two years.
He had known us both and it was
playing that he understood the anguish,
but there were other things to think about
as we knew only too well.
The brigadier told us our ammunition.
It was nearly finished and as
her own fire slackened the enemy,
snipers were becoming bolder
and more men were being hit.
Soon we would be forced to surrender,
so we had decided to take the initiative.
We would break out
towards the rooster beak,
charging through the enemy and solid mass,
trusting our numbers and
impetus to get through.
It was an extraordinary plan for the
second time that day the brigadier was
ordering us to do what seemed impossible,
but our trust and the brigadier,
his judgment was now implicit.
It was a gamble,
but one which offered at
least a chance of success
to stay here would only one end one way.
15 minutes later we were ready.
It could have been the start of a race.
The brigadier asked whether we were ready,
then add his shout.
The hundred of us rose to our feet and
exploded in a solid mass over the lip of
a hollow in front was the brigadier
himself leading the way behind came the
yelling, screaming men filthy and
bloodstained weapons in their hands,
band nets, dull and menacing. A
fearful site to anyone in our path.
The German fire now seem to be coming from
every direction, but I saw no one hit.
We were rushing downhill along us lane,
a solid human battering ram.
The first wild play pay
slackened the firing stopped.
We had done it.
We were through the enemy and out
of the forest for the second time,
that day boldness to it saved us
once again, some default
aggressive activity. And,
and I mean obviously I want to make it
clear that emboldened the both these
situations, it wasn't, it wasn't, uh,
it wasn't a call of, hey,
there's a, there's a,
there's a objective we want to reach.
Charge it.
Hmm.
It was, we can either sit here and
do nothing and die or we can attack.
That's the, that's the big, I don't
want anyone out there thinking, okay,
I'm just going to,
every time default aggressive,
I'm going to run and
we're going to attack. No.
These are situations where the alternative
to attacking is is being defensive,
laying down and dying and continue to
get picked off and snipers until you get
overrun.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now they meet up with, finally they
meet up with these other British troops.
Back to the book. Someone was leading
us into a garden of a large house.
The men dropped to the
ground as they halted,
conscious that they were now safe with
houses and other British Air British
troops around them. Others after a
swig from a water bottle, lay supine,
unconscious. In instance,
sleep. I counted them.
Jimmy Gray,
John Simmons and sergeant wine or were
there sergeant major Kelly was missing.
Someone had seen him fall in the rush.
There were just 49 other men about half
from c company last night there had been
200 the night before,
now they're in these positions
and
they're about to get attacked just
below in the garden, but out of sight.
Another brand opened up. It was Jimmy
Gray Century at the garden gate.
There was a glimpse of a camouflage figure
running through the trees opposite no
more than a hundred yards away,
diagonally across our front towards the
air landing troops. Then a couple more,
Jimmy's Bren fired again and one of the
figures pitched forward rolling over,
carried on by its own momentum.
We would not, we would have to fight
and this is their, they're talking,
he's talking about the fact that
they're in the houses now in these,
in this village, we would have
to fight from the house itself,
not from the trenches in the garden.
It was a sturdy building with
thick solid walls. In any case,
the garden was too small for the
purpose from these upper windows.
We would have an extra range
and observation to fire
diagonally down the road in
front of the houses held by units to
the left and right. 15 minutes later,
the Trim Dutch house had been wrecked.
Every pane of glass had been smashed and
every picture and mirror knocked from
the walls. There was no time to be
careful in the center of each room.
Barricades been built well back from
the windows out of sight of the boat,
but cited so that every scrap
of ground outside was covered.
Sideboards and chest of drawers
stuffed with books or bedding made the
barricades contents of the furniture
flung in heaps into corners of the rooms.
Mattresses were rolled
down to the basement,
ready for use if needed by wounded men.
More books crammed into drawers were
blocking those windows not required for
shooting through.
Fortunately,
the owner of the House possessed to find
library from its content seemed a lose.
A doctor with gray.
I walked around the house for a final
check before leaving to return to my own
headquarters at the rear.
Manic vandals might've swept through it.
Some woman's life work ruined in the
time it took to drink a cup of coffee.
An explosion from above followed by the
clatter of tiles falling from the roof,
drowned out the noise from the gun.
Another bomb burst in the
garden just outside the window,
sending a couple of fragments
whistling into the room.
Now the Bush were hitting
us with mortars as well.
A bullet splintered of the empty frame
behind me and buried itself in the
ceiling. A warning that I was far
too close to the back bedroom window.
There was a sniper behind
us as well as the Spandau.
A quick movement in the garden
of the house caught my eye.
Then two figures in the wrong sort of
camouflage darted from behind a Bush and
did the shelter of a wall.
They were Boesch, not British,
so now the enemy was indeed all around us.
There was no doubt about it.
Now John Simmons and his men were in
the houses where they had been left that
morning. John had made strong
points out of a couple of houses,
smaller but just as robust
as the ones held by gray.
The two groups had been
working closely together.
Largely I felt certain because of John's
charm of manner and determination,
this young Gunnar had done very well.
It hardly seems possible that most
of his men hardly knew him by sight.
Yesterday.
Today he is welded.
The survivors of four different companies
have a unit into have another arm into
a tight knit entity,
well capable of carrying
on the fight all day.
They'd held from killing and wounding
quite a lot of enemy but losing only one
man themselves.
A corporal have a company whose hand had
been blown in half by a flying mortar,
splinter
lined and filthy.
Though his face was eyes,
red rimmed and Chin stained
with three days worth of fare,
fuzzy down.
John still moved briskly.
Our reminder to all of us that
we could still keep going.
So he's got guys that
are stepping up big time.
Okay.
Inside the houses we felt reasonably
safe from the shells and bullets,
but there was always some cause for the
officers and senior NCO is to move about
in the open from building to another.
It was the same as it had been in the
woods, the officers and sergeants,
so this trade or greater chance of
being killed or wounded as their men,
all the same. It was easier for
an officer with so much to do.
He had little time to worry
about his own safety also.
He always had to try and act the part
to set an example to the others and
officer had to exude confidence,
however hard it might be,
but because he always had to
try to keep a grip on himself,
it helped him forget the danger.
Very true. Very true. Got a
lot of things on your mind.
They get a massive bombardment in
these positions that they're in.
Back to the book of the Germans must
be softening us up in preparation for
something more serious.
Their ammunition seemed unlimited.
The bombardment ended quite
suddenly rather as it had started.
This would be it nudging Williams to get
his head up from behind the barricade.
I shouted a warning to the others,
Elkins and Bauer in the next room and
the two signalers who had moved up to the
bedroom at the back. The starter of
the Bren gun caught across the war,
the words Bauer's rifle fudded next door,
and then Williams was firing a succession
of bursts from his Bren gun in the
orchard opposite. Germans were
running through the trees towards us.
Several dropped.
This could only be the start of
an attack now from either flank,
the sound of rifles and machine guns
reached us accompanied by the thought of
exploding grenades. The attack
was coming in all along our front.
Some of the Germans among the fruit
trees were firing back a couple of rifle
bullets, splintered the front of the
wardrobe. Then more gray figures.
We're lumbering towards
us through the trees.
Some fell all there's ducked
behind the puny trees.
They didn't stand a chance.
It was like shooting targets
on the press practice range.
The Germans and the mortars
had been forced to stop
because their troops were so
close. It was so, it was,
it was possible to fire slow,
carefully aimed shots with
little or no distraction.
The only way out of the orchard was
through the single gap in the high fence,
but the enemy soldiers never
got within 20 yards of it.
A Tall German officer was standing in
the middle of the drive out in the open,
clear of the trees,
waving his arms to the men behind him.
No more than 50 yards away.
Every detail of his face and
uniform was clearly visible.
He was a handsome young man, fair
haired, and smartly turned out
already.
He'd been standing there for about five
seconds encouraging his men to advance.
As I leveled my sights
on the German officer,
I knew that I was at someone
who is just about to die.
It seemed a pity. He was such a
courageous boy, just the sort,
just the sort one would like to
have had as a platoon commander.
My fingers started to squeeze the trigger,
but it was too late.
Someone else had fired.
The German fell,
spread eagled and lay still.
At least he died quickly.
The death of the young officer
mark the end of the attack.
Now,
no one moved in the orchard except for
a single wounded man squirming his way
back through the trees.
So it's interesting when you,
you take the leader and the leader
goes down and the attacks over. Hmm.
Now,
uh,
also it's important to note that although
the leader stood up and encouraged the
attack by taking that risk of being out
there in front of everyone, in this case,
it didn't work out well
because he got shot,
killed and the attack faltered.
Perhaps if he could have found a little
bit better of a position to do that from
then,
then maybe then maybe he would have been
able to encourage his troops and stay
alive.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
But we had one no more than a temporary
respites 15 minutes later we could hear
the unnerving noise once again,
tracks were clattering towards us.
So I haven't, I don't know why
I haven't talked about this yet,
but here you have these airborne troops
on the ground and their biggest fear is
tanks.
And you've heard me talk many times
about my love for tanks and how effective
and awesome they are as tools and as
a weapons and the way that the tankers
utilize them. They're just,
they're just awesome machines.
But here you have the tables turned
and and the good guys don't have real,
any effective way of stopping these tanks.
You can shoot a machine
gun all day long at a,
at a panzer tank and it's
not going to do a damn thing.
And so it can just, and by the way,
you hide in the building, cool a tank.
We'll go right through a building.
They go right through buildings.
They will go right through a building
like it looks like a construction piece of
heavy equipment.
That's what it looks like.
It'll go right through a
building like it's nothing.
So these guys are absolutely
horrified of the tank showing up.
That's their fear.
Tram tracks were clattering toward us,
a gun funded and the dark
red house opposite began to
fall apart as round after
round crashed into it.
Muzzle flashes from the far side of the
orchard revealed the position of the,
but there was nothing we could do.
At least the men.
We're not waiting in the house but
slipping one after another out the door,
back across the road to the
headquarter house on either side.
The guns were firing.
Now it was our turn,
the the
tank rex, some of the houses
and then it the tank leaves.
So here we go. It's, it
was time to strike back.
The tanks had gone and as yet the Bose
did not appear to have occupied the
houses lying out there in the rear
gardens overlooked from the windows.
We were vulnerable indeed.
Soon the mortaring would start again,
then we'd be safe for back
in the ruined buildings.
As John Simmons listened
to the instructions,
the young captains manor
was as relaxed as ever,
calm and outwardly self confident.
He somehow managed to give the impression
that he was almost enjoying the
morning's work.
Possibly he was making
that a point subconsciously
perhaps that are gunner could
always take charge of 30 infantry men,
but there were undoubtedly immense rose
reserves of strength hidden behind that
cool exterior.
As he lay behind the bed of half dead
pea plants scanning the houses for any
sign of German occupants.
There was no trace of disquiet and his
voice as he discussed his orders to
counter attack and clear
the street to the enemy.
15 minutes after John had gone,
I was still in the same
place in the vegetable patch
watching the second hand on
my watch creep towards
the top of the dial.
Then graze weapon opened up on the right,
firing back in the back into
the rooms of the houses,
more in the hope of distracting the enemy.
Then providing covering fire.
The danger to John's men lay on the
other side, the front of the houses.
Now John's three brand guns
were firing as well on the left.
The assault party would soon
be moving into the street.
It came
the sustained rattle of a Spandau Gun,
first one,
then a second.
Okay.
After that there was silence
except for one or two rifle shots.
I waited lying in the vegetable patch,
almost a straw with worry.
Something was badly wrong.
Nothing could be seen from here,
but I had to resist the temptation of
going to find out for myself what had
happened. I must avoid getting
involved in the skirmish.
Then Corporal Day,
now John's second in command was running
through the flower beds toward me.
Days. Face said everything even
before he started to speak.
Okay?
The attack had failed.
It had failed the moment John had been
killed out there in the middle of the
street and 10 yards in front of day
and the rest of the assault party,
John had died in just the same way as
that young German officer this morning
that had finished it.
The rest of them,
including day had turned and run,
but in some extraordinary way.
No one else had been hit
day made no excuse,
no attempt to excuse himself,
telling the story factually and not
trying to put a gloss on the incident.
The implication was clear.
They had been asked to do too much.
So now I had been responsible
for killing John as well.
Okay.
It had been so simple.
I issued the orders and then John had
walked out into the middle of that road to
be shot down by the machine gun.
I should not have done it right.
The counter attack should
never have been attempted.
The men were no longer capable
of making such an effort.
They could still hang onto their
positions fighting from behind cover,
but after six days of continuous battle,
they lack the will to get to
their feet and go for the enemy
in the woods.
It had just been possible to urge them
forward in one last surge of willpower,
but since then they didn't dirt
or a further 48 hours of death,
starvation, thirst, and
fatigue, and in the woods,
it was men from my own company.
Today, it had been different. Today,
a mixture of men,
survivors of four different companies
had been left to follow a gunner officer
whom they hardly knew.
There was a limit to what soldiers could
be asked to do and I had gone beyond
those limits
and so John Simmons had died.
Okay.
That's the burden of command.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
it was impossible to understand why the
Germans were not using their arm or to
support this infiltration by their
infantry if they had done so,
all resistance would have collapsed long
ago and the tanks would have been on
the lawns.
Yeah.
The crushing news at the
brigadier had been badly wounded,
came through on the telephone just
before the line went dead. Once again,
the Boesch,
we're now among the houses and gardens,
which the glider pilots had been holding
and gray had reported that he was being
shot at from two sides at the same time.
The quarter master had also sent word
that the enemy were behind him and that he
had long ago lost all contact
with the recky on his left.
Okay.
They are just in a wretched state and he
goes to meet with the colonel in one of
the buildings. The colonel seemed
to be trying to break something to,
to us gently and then it came out.
It was hard to believe,
harder still to understand the division
was to be withdrawn over the Rhine that
night. It was all over. It had been,
it had only been possible to ferry about
250 men of the door sits over the river
before dawn, a profit lists
addition to the perimeter garrison,
the second army had overreached itself
and trying to get to us and although the
troops were pouring northward,
they lack the strength across the river
and continued the advance into Germany
already the bush,
we're hammering from the flanks at
their narrow lines of communication,
so the operation had failed.
Everything had been in vain.
It was all a waste.
Listening to the outline of
what had to be done that night,
it was hard to concentrate on the details.
Okay.
The first emotion was grief
and then other disappointment.
The battalion had been
destroyed to no purpose
and that's it.
They get the order that night to
leave and they come up with a plan.
They actually follow rope.
They put rope at night down towards
the river where they're going to get
extracted and at night they attempt
to follow that rope down there.
And of course along the way they
lose more men. Men Get separated,
men don't hang on,
they get lost and they lose even more
men as they're trying to make it to their
extraction point.
But he does get end up with a small
group of people at this extraction point.
There's Canadian boats there to
bring them across the Rhine River.
Back to the book,
the Canadians were already pulling the
last men into the boat and I was standing
with Harrison alone in the river when
I heard the whiners voice harshly
insisting that no one would be left behind
the young Cox and needed no further urging
button poured us to be careful as the
boat was grossly overloaded.
Okay.
Then Harrison pushed me up over the side
and the two of us flopped down behind
the and as the engine went into gear and
the boat move towards the mid stream.
So now they get across the
river, they get dropped off. And,
and to answer your question earlier,
once they get dropped off and
they're on the other side of the,
they're on the western side of the
Rhine River. It's basically secure area.
Even though it was only, you
know, several hundred yards away,
it was relatively secure and now what
they have to do is they have to march back
about five miles to get to
a even more secure base.
Here we go back to the book
as we reached the track,
which after a few hundred yards
let us to the road when I stopped,
the men flopped to the ground,
empty and lifeless,
lacking any wish to go on more parties
of men appeared for the darkness
shambling in the exhaustion of relief,
all terror ended,
devoid of the willpower needed
to summon up further effort.
There was only one way to make the two
mile march bearable and old fashioned
remedy.
I called the Sergeant Weiner to fall.
The men in threes,
the discipline bark bounced back to me
as wiener pulled himself to his feet,
shouting to the men to fall in.
There was no trace of query or surprise
in whiners voice and the men shuffled to
their feet.
That's,
that's your route training right there,
that you're exhausted after eight days
of continuous combat, you're just done.
And the sergeant says,
all right,
on your feet form a column
of threes and you do it.
They're getting close to the end.
I'm now,
they can see the camp and I hosted them.
There was only one way to end such
a march. It was pointless perhaps.
But I decided to make the final gesture,
bringing them to attention.
I ordered them to slope, arms and
demarche by the left to attention.
I sensed their appreciation as
there's shoulders went back.
This was the way they
always returned to camp.
This was the way they always finished.
As they stepped off for the last 50 yards,
they were even swinging their arms.
So they march back into this camp.
Once they get into this camp,
they get loaded up into uh,
a vehicle,
a big military transport vehicle that's
going to take them further to the rear
where they can get some treatment
and they're loaded into that for you.
Cool
and here we go. Back to the book, the
canopy of the truck now sheltered us,
but my shivering became uncontrollable.
I knew I was becoming light headed and
could hear myself grieving allowed for
those that we had left behind,
particularly for those who had been lost
during the withdrawal down the river
bank.
There was silence in the truck.
Then I heard as if from a long way off
the voice of Sergeant Weiner clon calm
and flat saying that none of them would've
got back if it had not been for me.
It was true to say that I would never
have got back if it hadn't been for them,
but I shall always be grateful
to Weiner for having said it.
The next thing I remember was Weiner
and Harrison half carrying me into what
seemed to be a hospital.
Yeah,
someone was stripping off my
clothes and dressing me in pajamas.
Then I felt the prick
of a needle in my arm.
I was awake.
The Sun shining into the
windows of the award,
an orderly brought tea and food on a tray.
I laid between the clean sheets,
looking at the torn and filthy garments
on the chair by the side of the bed.
There was nothing wrong with me.
Now
I saw that my hand was
wrapped in a clean bandage.
When the nursing orderly
came to remove the tray.
He brought me the message that a soldier
was waiting in the corridor to see me.
As soon as the orderly left the room,
I slipped out of bed and put on my
clothes and went out into the corridor
waiting.
There was Harrison,
a broad smile on his face telling me that
captain gray and Mr Elkins and turned
up with eight of the missing men.
Another 20 stragglers had also
arrived from somewhere or another,
but that was the lot.
That was the battalion
three officers and 43 soldiers.
We walked out the door
of the hospital side
side by side,
the week September sun shone
down on the battered buildings.
I'll way in the distance,
the dull rumble of the battle
still rolled down from the north
and
once
all the men were recovered, and
that's, that's the end of the book.
And when all the men were recovered it,
and when you look at the actual battalion
of 156 the parish parachute battalion,
it looked like this. 313 men were
captured. Many of those were wounded.
There was 98 killed in action and there
was a total of 68 from the battalion
that made it across the Rhine safely
and those 68 men,
if they could heal up,
were then sent to the
other battalions inside.
The first pair of Rubber Dade and the
hundred and 56th parachute battalion was
actually disbanded.
It ceased to exist.
Jeffry Powell went on
to retire from the army,
the British army in 1964 he
retired as a major general.
He was awarded the military cross,
which is Britain's third
highest award for valor
and this is what his citation reads at
Arnhem numb after his commanding officer
had become a casualty,
Major Powell took command of the remnants
of the battalion up to this time.
He conducted himself with the greatest
gallantry for the remaining six days.
He retained control of his unit and also
of the men of other units in the area
under the most difficult conditions.
Heavy fire for mortars, artillery and
self propelled guns never stopped,
is it activity?
And getting round his section of the
perimeter and encouraging his men to
greater efforts
throughout the whole period of the and
m battle. In spite of being wounded,
this officer showed himself to be a
gallant leader of men and the most capable
fighter and one whose bravery was a
source of inspiration to the men under his
command and to all those around him.
And I think it's pretty clear that
if you will read a book like this,
General Powell is still a source of
inspiration as are the rest of these
incredibly brave men.
Okay.
And also a source of leadership lessons
of what to do and what not to do.
And it's also an incredible reminder
of that heavy burden of command.
And the fact of the matter is,
when you lead,
you own every decision and every action,
not only of yourself,
but of your men.
And with that burden,
you owe it to them.
Yeah.
To be as well prepared to be as tactically
sound and to be as physically and
mentally strong as you can possibly be.
And that goes for any leadership
position when you're a leader,
be as prepared as you possibly can.
And then you go out and you lead and
you lead with courage and you lead with
resolution and you lead with boldness,
boldness like Jeffrey Pal,
then the officers and the
men of the hundred and 50,
sixth parachute battalion.
Pretty amazing book that,
you know,
like I said,
I got this book six days ago or something,
somebody just sent it to
me and I gave it the um,
the little tests when I kind of opened
books up cause people send me a lot of
books and I gave it the, uh, I gave
it the test. You know, I opened up,
I read a couple sections and it
immediately, you know, I'll give, I'll,
I'll open to a book and four
or five different places
to see what it reads like.
And this, you know, within the first page,
the first page that I read, I said, oh,
we,
it looks like we have a winner here.
This one's going to be on the
podcast because it's just impactful.
And the account. Now, the,
in the back of the book,
he talks about the,
the individuals, just read some of
them off here. The brigadier was
General John Hackett.
The colonel was Dickie Divo
of the Grenadier guards.
His fellow granted year was sergeant
major, sergeant major dentist,
Gay, his Batman, the
guy that he talks about,
Harrison throughout the book,
the guy that's there from
the beginning to the end,
always by his side.
That was actually a guy named Fred Tracy,
a guy named David [inaudible] went in
the book is the character in the book.
The real guy was named Michael Page,
who had been Powells best man and
whose son Jeffery born posthumously had
another son named Michael
and Luke Tyler and Sergeant
Wiener and Jones and Johnson,
as these were all real
people. So, you know,
this is another guy that uh,
very similar to major John Glover who
said he had a hard time writing about
himself in the first person. You
know, I did this and I did that,
but it's the same thing that Powell said.
You know,
he had a hard time writing until
he just made it about some other,
he made some other character in his
hand and vote from that perspective.
But man, you definitely, this book I,
like I said, I read, I
don't know, 5% of it.
It's not a huge book though actually.
It's only a couple of hundred pages
long and it's a very fast read.
Did you find it to give you this weird
stressful feeling reading now? Absolutely.
Like listening to, it's like just
more stress, stress. It is. And I was,
I was debating when to tell you
and when to tell everyone that,
that this is not a good, that
this isn't a good story, right.
That this isn't a positive thing.
And I kinda just, I don't know.
When I actually said that, hey,
they're not going to win. I mean, I said
that the, the operation market garden was,
it was a failure, but you know,
what does that really look like?
You know what I mean?
Like you don't know what that looks
like until you get reading this book and
then you start to feel what
it feels like an absolutely.
And when you read the whole book,
man, it is just coming apart.
It's just little misfortune,
little miss four.
And they're just coming in and they
don't stop. They just don't stop.
It's a,
it's a nightmare scenario and yeah,
and there's tons of great lessons learned.
It's so,
it's so amazing because I never read
this book before. I just got it. Yeah.
But it's amazing. Cover move.
Yeah. Decentralized Command.
Even prioritize and execute.
Even the apart when you're
keeping it simple, right?
Everything that, that we
learned that, you know,
I should've learned this years ago
and when I think about, you
know, I was, you, you, you
look back at your life, right?
And you say to yourself, what could I have
done better? What could I do different?
And you know,
everyone in the seal teams,
like basically you get one shot at
each job other than just being uh, uh,
a shooter and a platoon that you can
do three or four times if you're lucky.
But then once you get into a
leadership position, you're like,
you're an assistant platoon commander,
you do that one time,
then you're a platoon commander,
then you're a task unit commander. You
do that one time. Generally some guys,
sometimes the guys rarely guys do more
than one of those same thing on the
enlisted side.
Guy Gets to do an uh,
a leading petty officer does that one
time chief petty officer of a platoon,
platoon chief does that one time.
Senior chief in charge of a
task unit does that one time.
You don't get to repeat the jobs.
And so basically when you're
finally getting good at your job,
you're done and now you've got to go get
the next job up the chain of command.
So for me it was always, and now looking
back and, and, and even talking to,
talking to my seal buddies now,
like,
like how can we prepare them better so
they know what we had to learn during the
job. It's, it's,
it's a hard thing to do because it's
because a lot of stuff that you actually
have to learn from experience.
And actually we talked about that
at the last muster, which is,
that was a big part that we talked about.
Your,
if you're going to get good at something,
you have two choices,
experience or training and
training as a way to condense,
experience down and distill it.
And that's what was great about when we,
when I was running training
on the west coast, we,
we got to really condensed that
experiential, I mean guys went through,
guys went through hellacious
training and we're,
we'd provide total chaos for them that
most guys wouldn't experience that kind
of chaos in their whole
career or in 10 careers.
But they would get it and they
would get pushed super hard.
So that way when they got out on the
battlefield they were ready for the,
for the chaos that was out there.
Cause we trained him and we pushed him
further and harder during training than
we hoped they would get pestered pushed
on the battlefield. Yeah. It was crazy.
Even though that covering move,
even when they're retreating it's like
it showed like how you got to keep that,
that discipline, that
discipline. It's kind of like,
you know like in an MMA fight or something
and the guy who starts getting hit on
the insight and rather than still covering
up a little bit while he goes back,
he like runs away or turns his
back or something like that.
You don't turn your back and you're done.
But great book.
I definitely recommend it for your
reading list. Yeah, there was a,
there was that part in there that the
guy came up to I think reload ammo or
something and the guy's sitting there
and he's just so he gets like scolded or
whatever and you know, it turns out these
wounded. Right. Like that's kind of,
that was an interesting little lesson
there. Like, you just don't know.
You can't just start going off
on. It's totally true. And,
and I don't know if you remember, somebody
asks us a question one time about,
you know, how do I, these people that
have had everything given to them and I,
and I, you know, I've had, I grew up in
a tough neighborhood and it's like, oh,
you didn't, you actually don't know
what that person's been through.
And we had that whole discussion.
That's the same thing.
True on a day to day basis
with every other human being
that you're dealing with.
You don't know what they're going through.
You don't know what triumphs and
tragedies they've had in their life.
You don't know what just
happened to them this morning.
So the recommended course of action as
you give someone a little bit of slack
when you don't know him,
you know,
you ever seen that at Seinfeld when he
either goes to talk to that girl, come on.
It was actually, it was, it was pretty
much this, but just on Seinfeld.
So he goes to talk to this guy. He's
like, oh, I got to talk to that girl.
She's hot. Whatever. He goes up to, and
he's like, he's like, hey, hey, hello,
excuse me. And her back has
kind of turned, you know,
he's like, excuse me, hello?
Hello? Like getting any starts to get
real mad that she's not listening to him.
Finally he walks like more close to her
and she kind of starts to turn around
and he's like, oh, so now
you pay attention. What are
you deaf? And she's like,
Bingo. Like signs to
them. Oh, she is death.
You know where you got to chill out.
Yeah.
I'll find out about people for free start.
They make sure the regimental sergeant
major isn't wounded and both legs before
you start dressing him
down. I know. Yeah, man,
that's a good thing he put
that in this book. You know?
That's pretty humble for him to put
this in this book. You know what I mean?
And that other part where
there were all what?
Like tired and stuff, right? Or they're
defeated essentially. They were actually,
you mean when they were broken?
Men. Yeah. And then they,
and they got up and they just started
charging, getting that default aggressive.
Yeah. Yeah. The default, the default
aggressive apart. That's like, um,
like in Hawaii there's big centipedes no,
then they're like,
they're kind of, they're like, no, no,
they're bigger than like send a
pizza that I've seen here. Okay.
Give me a figure like six inches,
12 it's six is like a normal,
big centerpiece.
Cinches they'll get bigger anyway
there. I mean, compared to you,
you know that there, there are little
bugs, they're little, right, whatever,
and you just step on it.
But like when you start messing
with it and it starts to get nuts,
it's superintendent,
I don't know.
But they can chase you out of your room.
You've got chased out of your robot,
even like a,
like a wasp or you don't like with these
little things that are way smaller than
you and they just get nuts and then, and
like, you didn't want to mess with it,
you know? So Lafe Lafe was over. My house
is a while ago, a couple of years ago.
And,
uh,
there was a lizard in my house
like about a nine inch lizard.
And so my son and Lafe are going
to try and catch this lizard and,
and they're being weak. They're like,
yeah, exactly. You're like, oh, you know,
they're like, oh wait, wait, no, grab
it, get a box on it and all that stuff.
So I come in, Mister tough guy,
you know, I come in, reached, I go,
just grab that thing.
You will cease reached down.
I reached down to grab this thing,
this thing turns its head and bytes
and I screamed like a,
like the Jim Carrey like right.
Oh yeah.
Flick my hand.
It was,
it was absolutely hilarious cause I went
from being a big tough guy to screaming,
um,
oh,
having a lizard bit on my
finger Jube blood by the way.
I drew blood. Yeah. All my thumb. So yeah,
I was default aggressive, but
it didn't work out. The, the,
the lizard was more default aggressive
than I was. Yeah. See and the end,
that is funny. That's a funny story
for a couple of reasons in my opinion.
But that is the exact same concept
though. You know, where if you would, uh,
like how you said in the book just kept
your head. You smashed that Lizard,
all the five one to catch it alive.
I wasn't trying to kill it. Yeah.
But still I should have been
more aggressive like the
buyer and the bite didn't
even hurt. Right. Yeah. I just
shocked me. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wasn't ready for the, the gnashing
of the teeth getting nuts. Yeah.
Those lizards, we have a lot of those,
especially when he gets hot. I mean,
I'm assuming it's the same time there
are these, but here's the thing.
Growing up on Kauai, there's these things
they call them, we call them chameleons,
but they're like, uh, no.
Uh, no. Lay a n, m, O, l. E,
that's he spent spell it. They, they turn
green or brown or whatever and they get,
they get pretty big and they're super
aggressive. Like when you grab them, oh,
that's the first lift.
Red thing comes out of their neck and
they start biting you and you get till
when you hold them after a while
they start to calm down. Yeah,
I think they just start to get
sick and stuff. I Dunno. I Dunno.
But they calmed down. So you can do
this thing where basically a kid, if he,
if you have the Lizard Ted,
you go like this and he'll go like that.
He'll try to bite you. So what you do
is when he comes down on it, what ray,
when you grab him, he's trying to kill
you. But when he calms down after,
I don't know, three, four minutes,
you do that and he'll kill,
keep kinda like he'll do less
and less and less. Less and less.
He'll always do that though,
but it'll just be a lot less aggressive.
And then if you put your finger in his
mouth, he'll bite you and he won't let go.
So you got to kind of drag
your finger out and yet it'll,
it can cause blood or whatever.
But what we do is,
and you can see pictures of this,
we do that and we'd put it on,
put the lizard on our ears. So the lizard
would be an earring and hearing yeah,
biting areas. You'd have two
lizards hanging down. But anyway,
the point there being
fun if you can keep your,
yeah, yeah. When you grow up with that
stuff, like those lizards are not scary.
Even if they're aggressive.
And some of them,
they get pretty like big and
bulky and they're like, Dang,
a state has some power to it. This little
lizard, you know. And, but even here I it,
when I grabbed them, they're like, oh no,
I wouldn't have screamed like you
explain the experiences with got me,
dude. It was awful. It
was awful. Well, um,
being prepared I guess is what we're
talking about, being aggressive.
Why don't you get default aggressive
with letting anybody know if they want to
support this podcast and
maybe how they could do it.
Also support Jockos
traumatizing experience with
a lizard and this lizard bite
his fingers and he was
screaming, who wasn't leaf in
who it was late. And my son.
Yeah. Did they lose respect
for you that time? Well,
it's actually funny cause Lafe
always talks about, you know,
me being calm and that's
why he laughed so hard. We,
we were driving one time and
we almost got in a car wreck.
He was driving actually,
and I'll have him tell the story,
but we hit mud and we hit,
we were out in the desert,
we're going 65 miles an hour on a
back road back by all these farms.
And it was two o'clock in the morning,
three o'clock in the morning,
something like that.
And normally these roads are completely
dry there in the desert and we're
hauling and laced drive and I
think he's driving his truck. Okay.
What's driving this truck we're
hauling and all of a sudden,
out of nowhere we see,
we see a big 18 wheeler on the side of
the road on the opposite side of the road.
But it's a narrow road. Yeah.
Yeah. And as we're hauling,
all of a sudden we hit a water walker,
probably a couple inches
deep of water when mud,
because it's what happened somewhere.
Irrigation from all this farmland
had broken and there was this flood.
And so we hit this thing and we're
immediately hydroplaning and,
and Lafe is from Texas.
Lafe is from Texas.
So he did not used to driving in the snow.
I grew up driving in the snow in
New England. You know, you just,
you just deal with it. Everyone's like
a rally driver up there. Yeah. Yeah.
That's so sad.
So and so leaf,
he is not really used to this.
And he starts to oversteer the car, which
is really, really bad. And you know,
I'm sitting there and we're
going 65 miles an hour. He, he,
he's funny when he tells a
story too because he's like, we,
we thought we were going to
die. He thought he'd exactly,
we were definitely die.
And I'm sitting there in the
passenger seat and I, and I say,
don't oversteer don't overstay. No
breaks, no breaks. Alright, you're good.
Cause that's the other thing, mistake
you can make. If you jam on the brakes,
you're going to lock it up
and you're going to slide,
you're going to lose control. So I just
don't understand it. Don't oversteer.
No breaks. No breaks.
Alright, you're good.
So that was not my reaction when I
got bit on the phone by the Lizard.
Ah,
it was hilarious.
Dang Bro. It's all good.
But Hey man, you know,
if you want to support this podcast, how
about this? Talk about that possible.
Do it. So one good way and support this
is, well, okay. This is what it is.
Origin, right? Origin, the brand
origin main.com. That's the website.
They've got a lot of cool stuff.
One of the cool items, actually,
there's a bunch are geese for Jujitsu.
I remember back when kind of won't
be first started this thing that's,
that would be the main question about
did you too was what kind of gear?
And I'd be like, Oh yeah, there's
these. And I give them the three.
The top actually there was,
there's four of them and it was shortly
after where you recommended this,
these origin ones. And then when
I went there I was like, oh shoot,
this is kind of expensive.
I don't know. You know?
But then I just looked
at the one that was like,
it was like the first one I saw it,
but there are many varying prices
of keys and they're all good.
By the way, I know this because
I asked them nonetheless.
If you're still wondering what kind of
Geeky to get origin g hundred percent you
have, um, options, you know, as
far as pricing and stuff like that,
if you want the deluxe one versus the
more basic one. But they're all dope.
And here's the thing about them.
They're all made in America and not in
the sense where they're just kind of
assembled in America, but so, you know,
the materials are sourced somewhere else.
The materials are sourced.
Would you call him sourced?
I guess the raw material
material comes from Tennessee,
South Carolina, South Carolina,
somewhere here. America.
I know that mark boom
brought over to Maine.
Assembled smooth illume. Yeah,
that's not a verb, right?
Yeah. Woven on a loom,
boom into this outstanding material.
Moisture, what do you call it?
[inaudible] right. That's when it
kind of like helps with my sister.
I didn't know all this,
by the way.
I'm being educated on it and
there's lots to know by the way. Um,
and I antimicrobial a big deal
anyway. Or do you mean.com?
That's where you get school stuff.
There's other stuff too, like rash guards
and even like clothes, regular clothes,
athletic wear. It's still anyway,
all made in America. Boom.
Also for some legitimate
fitness gear on it.com/jocko.
I just got the, I know I'm
into kettlebells. I know
I said that before. I'm a,
say it again. What is yours?
What is your heaviest Kettlebell?
You have 40 kilograms,
right? So 88 dots. Okay.
Mine's 94, by the way. I have two
of them. Oh, do you only have one?
I do only have one. I only have
one currently. Alright, well shoot,
I guess you know, it's clear what I
gotta do. Maybe I'll get another one,
step it up. But um, shoot, who was
I talking to about it? Oh yeah,
Morgan, you know Morgan,
right? We were talking,
we were talking about kettle bells
and some Morgan's feeling strong.
I told him that yesterday. Yeah.
Not, not just because that's,
it's kind of an insult in
Jujitsu. Yes. Yeah. Like, Hey,
you feel really strong city.
Yeah,
but I made it perfectly clear
yesterday. I was like, Hey,
you feel Jujitsu strong? I said, it's not,
I'm not trying to say you
feel strong like, hey, you're
a meat, you're a meathead,
but you feel strong in a positive way
because, and I said, here's the deal.
If it was just you being strong than five
years ago when I started training here
and be like, oh, you feel strong.
I didn't say it then because
you didn't feel strong.
You feel strong now that your
juice is getting better and,
and you're getting more skills.
Yeah.
I feel like we got to come up with a
different expression or maybe just a
modified expression because
some people, yeah, like they'll,
people tell me I'm strong or whatever,
and after awhile I was like, wait,
I felt the same thing that you one
time I told you like you're strong.
I thought it was kind of,
maybe subconsciously I thought it was
kind of established that, okay, look,
you're really good at Jujitsu. You know,
I thought that was kind of a given.
So if I were to tell you your song, it'd
be kind of like it. I like, Oh yeah.
I was like, we're like, no, my technique.
You're just like, no, my technique.
I was like, yeah, no, no. I know that. I
know your technique is outstanding. Yeah.
Little bit. Not In an angry way or
nothing like that, but actually surprise,
I wasn't, uh, a little bit more
sarcastic about it. See, okay.
And which to me, I'm surprised
that it and say, yeah,
I'm glad I'm so strong that I can just,
you know,
when people say it and I know people don't
mean it, I know they don't mean that.
How we take it kind of like you're
strong. It's your, your physical strength,
not your Jiu Jitsu technique.
That's what we take it as, you know,
and they're just throwing it in like
how essentially how I did with you.
It's kind of like, look, you're
better than you did to then me, you,
you beat me up all the time. But in
addition to that, you're pretty strong. I,
that's probably what people
were saying most of the time,
but so when people would be like, Dang,
you're strong, your grip, you don't,
when they say you're strong, I
say yeah, I lift a lot of weights.
So it kind of gives them the
impression kind of like yeah,
my weightlifting basically beats your
Jujitsu kind of thing and that's a more of
an insult, you know kind of
thing. But it's a joke really.
You know nonetheless.
So yes Morgan,
he's strong Jujitsu so he's technique
is strong so that means it's just a
technique is getting better and it and
it reveals it can deliver the strength in
the proper way. Yes. Good Job Morgan.
But we were talking about kettle
bells and he was like, Bro,
cattle catapults off hard.
So I started to feel kind of good because
I got this 90 pound one and I was like,
I lifted it up and you know, okay. You
know that's the one hand boom, clean,
clean press is their eggs.
If you,
you should legs to snap it
up there a little bit. Yes.
That is the clean and jerk.
Okay.
Even one hand if you just do,
if you don't use any legs and you just
powered up smoothly, that's oppressed.
Okay. So mine is clean and jerk. I Turkeys
the whole kind of body or whatever.
So my metcons they do, when
I got the Werewolf ones,
those are like 62 pounds. I do two
at a time. Boom, boom. Okay. Easy.
And you'd do reps, you
know, it's a little thing.
So I got the s the gorilla one's 72 pounds
and I can do that one just as you get
strong, you know? So I get the 90 pound
one. I'm like, I only got one too.
So I dunno. Do you think two at one time
is easier because of the balance? Right?
No, it's not easier. I mean
you using more energy for sure.
But as far as like doing the
ballot, not easier. Yeah. Okay.
Well so one is easier doing
one. One is for sure. He's
okay. Good. Well, okay, Gotcha.
So I got one big foot that's 90 pounds
and I lifted that off. I was like, man,
I'm not right.
And so it was like maybe two, three days
later I was like, well, I got to try.
That's the, you know, I got the 72
pound one, I can do that, you know,
a bunch of times actually.
But so I just warmed up a bunch
and just first time I did it,
like I straight up failed, I couldn't
do it. And I was like, all right,
all right and I know how it feels now
and all this stuff and then then I can do
it. Boom. Both your boom.
Yeah. Well that's good. Solid.
Glad we all know that now. Yup.
Hey God. And that's relevant.
Just say actually,
which is actually what makes kettlebells
kind of fun to do is because it does
require legitimate technique.
Like you can't, like it's hard.
It's like a dumbbell or
a barbell or a machine.
If you're doing barbell
snatches, it takes a hell. Yeah.
And that's really the spectrum,
you know? So if you go,
like if you're just kettlebell and
then dumb cause dumbbells a straight up
balanced,
I mean they're not,
they're not like a PR but they have
a handle both sides of the handle,
equal amount of weight, you know, boom.
You just have to balance your body and
then after you get that balance down,
this pretty easy barbell,
even less because you don't have
two sides gotta be balanced.
It's just one long thing and then
two sides of that is balanced.
Then you go machine, you don't even need
balance. You just need this tank to push.
So it's that spectrum to the kettle bell.
It's way on this side of the
spectrum where it kind of,
there's the game within the game, you
know? That's what makes it more fun.
I think you see progress in both areas.
Technique and strength.
Anyway,
we'll leave it at that.
If you want the cool kettle
bells on it.com/jocko or
jump ropes battle maces the
weight, do you call them battle
Macy's or just maces yeah,
those are kind of clubs. Yeah. Though
you can get some cool workouts with that.
And they like your forearms get
I,
I didn't look into like what exactly,
you know they're going to improve, but
I know core strength and all this stuff,
but there's all these little things
they improve to outstanding stuff. Also,
good way to support if you're going
to get this book men at how do you,
how do you pronounce it?
The place him art and Ham or
men aren't him Jeffry Powell.
That's how I pronounce it anyways. I'm
apologize to anyone that's from Holland.
Yeah.
And pronounces it a different way.
I looked at it on youtube and how they
set it and there was like they say, oh,
how to pronounce Our Name and
there's 14 different ways to say it.
So I just rolled the dice and pick one
that sounded easiest for me to say.
So sorry if I'm saying it wrong.
Hey Man. No, all good. Um,
but if you want to get that book or any
other book that Jack or reviews on the
website, just go to Jocko
podcast.com on the top menu.
Then click on books from episodes.
All the books are listed there by
episode along with the few other things,
but mainly just the books by episode.
You Click through there, boom,
takes you to Amazon, get those books
there. That's a good way to support this.
The Amazon Click through or
if you do any other shopping,
if you're getting a tripod or a video
camera or duct tape or whatever,
click through there. Boom. That's a good
way to support. Great Way to support.
Also a little addition there.
You know how we had the uh,
website Jocko podcasts to [inaudible]
dot com that's a, there's a long story.
I think I went into it.
It was like when I was like testing,
like what website provider,
whatever. I was like,
let me get this one because what if I'm
attached to it and it's a long story and
then so we ended up getting
Jocko podcast.com and
they're both kind of there,
but Jack podcast too was kind of the,
the the primary one.
It's not the primary one anymore.
Jocko podcast.
It's Jocko podcast.com okay,
so that's good website.
And that was actually a trooper.
That's straight up goddess Jocko
podcast looking out for us cause he,
and then that's a big deal. So
I'm in New York. Good Dude. Yeah,
that's a huge deal because um, like
do you have your own name? Yeah.
Okay. So people will be like,
Oh this guy's blowing off.
They'll go and they'll
buy the domain name.
Either hold onto it or immediately
go to you and be like, Hey,
you want to buy this from me? Yeah,
they hold it hostage. In fact,
I think there might be like a
legal like defense against it.
Like if someone gets your name or your,
your kid's name and your kind of a public
figures, I think, I'm not sure. But yeah,
that's what people do.
Men,
they'll or they'll buy a bunch of domain
names that sound cool and they'll be
like, yeah, you can buy
this from me kind of thing.
It's super whack when they do it
with like Euro, you know when,
no, that's your company or your
CEO hat for a long time. They,
I don't know what they paid for eventually
paid for ufc.com but for a long time
they were like the ufc.tv and all these
other UFC, but they had to step up.
I bet you they, I bet somebody made
a lot of money off that one. Yeah.
Especially the three letters I guess.
Like if you get the last
letter tomorrow morning,
crazy town nonetheless. But yeah, Jocko,
podcast.com that's the main website.
Now if you were going to Jocko podcast
too.com, it's not that anymore.
Does that sound to you though over? Uh,
it, it does. Did, but while I'm switching,
I'm doing this thing. It will eventually,
yes. But if you run into that,
that's why God will have been hitting
me up and rightly so. Thanks for that.
Um, so yeah, none the
less back to the point.
If you want to support and by getting
these books go through the website and
clicked through there, it's a good way
to support small action. Huge reaction.
Small, huge. That's how it works.
Also, subscribe to the podcast
iTunes. If you haven't already, stitcher,
if you don't use I o s I film Google play
any anywhere they where they provide a
podcast. Boom, we're on
there. So subscribe. That's
a good way. Also Youtube.
Yes. I put some excerpts on there. More
excerpts. I'm gonna continue to do so.
Shareable excerpts. Tried to
keep them under four minutes.
That's cool. Right? For
Yeah.
Might be a little long.
But I every once in a while you get it
like a good like 10 minute one though for
sure thing.
But they're more shit better than to
think about what the video is that you,
you want to get compression. Three
minutes, four minutes tops. Yeah.
And it depends on the, you should edit
them. Maybe like make them shorter.
Hmm. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean if it's appropriate because
sometimes you don't want to,
sometimes it's just you saying like a
whole thing and it's like okay that's
solid and sometimes it's you.
And then my rebuttal to kind of kind
of bolster the point, your point.
Cause you'll clarify it because I, you
know, and it's all, it's, it makes sense.
So sometimes if you edit certain things
out and maybe the message isn't there as
much as maybe it should be. Not
all the time, not all the time,
but most of the time unless I'll
look into it. How about that?
Ideally if a video,
and this goes along with like people's
typical like attention span should be
what?
Like about a minute and a half.
I don't know. But my attention span
is getting tested right now. Right.
Just
saying we this is important stuff.
We need to go over this so we can come
to the conclusion on how to conduct
ourselves in regards to youtube
excerpts and other things.
Nonetheless, subscribe to
Youtube Channel. It's good.
We're going to provide
value. How about that? No.
All if you're into the video version,
cause some people are,
some people are into more
the video version of the
podcast. Yeah. You know, boom.
Subscribe if you haven't already.
Youtube also Jocko has a store.
It's called Jocko store.
Jacqueline [inaudible] dot com and
if you didn't already know, um,
on there we've got some cool stuff.
Shirts, mainly some rash guards.
I just made an order for
hoodies. Thicker, heavier
fall is coming.
Are we in fall right now?
The fall was the first day of fall was
like the other day we are in fall. Yeah.
So we got some, not that we're
doing a whole seasonal thing.
I'm just saying it's fall now.
Getting cool eating cooler check.
Got Some hoodies on there.
I've got some shirts on there.
Got some rash guards on there.
I think I'm going to do
a warrior kid rash guard.
I have one but it's not in production yet.
Yeah. And it's not, I'm going
to change it a little bit,
some coloring stuff and whatever,
but it is pretty cool. Good,
good little pre response.
Um,
also hats on there and
some other cool stuff.
I'm not saying get something I'm
saying go on there, check it out.
If you want to support and
you want to get something,
he thinks something is cool for yourself
or for your, you know, friend, wife,
girlfriend, neighbor, whoever.
Didn't get something good way to support
actually a great way to support also
psychological warfare. Okay.
What psychological warfare
is. If you don't know,
it's an album
with Jocko tracks.
So basically if you're on your campaign
against weakness and you have a moment
of weakness,
this is like a little spot.
So basically you put on these
audio tracks to let you know,
hey, pragmatically, don't
skip this workout today. Hey,
don't slip on this diet today.
Hey,
your procrastination isn't
working and here's why,
but it's chocolate telling you.
So it's kind of like more effective,
way more effective. Hundred percent
success rate in my experience.
100%
that's legit. Yeah. A also
Jocko white tea, if you want it,
you can get that on Amazon.
It tastes good and it makes you feel
good also on origin main.com you can get
Jocko Super Krill Krill oil
that will make you feel good.
And on top of that you can
get Jocko joint warfare,
which is awesome. What's
in that, by the way?
It's glucosomine can droid and
those are the main, the main,
but then we put some additional
things in there. Um, yeah, and it's,
it's been rocking it.
It's,
it's awesome. You've got books or I've
got some books if you want to read them.
One is called way of the warrior kid.
One is called extreme ownership.
The Warrior kid book is for kids.
Extreme ownership is for
people in leadership positions
or people that want to
be in leadership positions.
There's also a new book coming out called
discipline equals freedom field manual.
It actually comes out October 17th
and at one point many months ago,
October 17th seemed like it was a
long ways away, but it's not anymore.
It's here so you can order that one.
It is unlike any book that you
have ever seen or read. Also,
what's interesting about this book is
people keep asking me if it's going to be
on the audible is not going to be on
audible. Hmm. Instead of being on audible,
it is going to be on iTunes.
It's going to be on Amazon,
MP three it's going to be on Google play.
It's going to be where you
can find MP three tracks.
There's a reason for this.
If you do it through audible,
you get this one big long book
and it's in what the book is.
The way the book is written,
it's written to be chunked up and you're
going to want to take parts of it and
play it at certain times more like you
would do with the psychological warfare
album. So people were asking
for more psychological warfare.
That's what we're doing.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's going to be available as an album
that you can buy and then you can do what
you want with the tracks.
You can make them your alarm ring tone,
you can listen to them out of order in
any order. You can put them into mixed.
You can do a lot more stuff with them.
That's why we're doing it as an album
with tracks instead of as an audible book.
So you know what we might,
you know,
people might have a little
challenge finding it or realizing,
you know when they go on to Amazon
or they go on to Barnes and noble,
they won't see that it's available.
There'll be looking for the audible.
Then you won't be able to find it.
I'm sorry. Yeah, we'll just an audible,
I think that's where they won't,
you won't find it in the audible
platform, right? Will not be there.
It'll be on Amazon.
It'll be on Amazon,
but I don't think it will be linked
in to the same thing where you go, oh,
here it is. I think it's going to be
hidden and it's gonna be hard to find.
Kind of like,
it's hard to find on iTunes.
It's hard to find psychological warfare,
but the question is, do you want to do,
did I want to do something right or just
do something easy? Yeah, that's true.
Because the field manual,
like any field manual,
like when you want to go refer to it,
you don't want to be searching around and
be like, okay, what does that one part?
You know that deals with this and boom,
you can just go to them.
You just look for the track
name and either, so like I said,
we could have done the easy thing and and
whatever, you know, had everyone just
being able to click on it real easy.
I apologize, but if you want the right
way then that's what I had to do.
So that's that book
and then Echelon Front,
that's the leadership consultant company
that I have with wave Babin with JP to
know Dave Burke.
If you want to have us coming to work
with your business contact info at echelon
front com
and if you have any questions or if you
have any answers or if you just want to
continue this conversation,
you can find us on the
Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram and on the Facebook e echo
is that Echo Charles and I am at Jocko
Willink.
And finally thanks to everyone out there
for making this podcast possible to
those of you in the military,
especially those right now on the forward
line of our own troops facing evil
every day.
Thank you for providing this freedom
that we enjoy and to the first responders
and law enforcements in fire and EMS.
Thank you for taking care of us while
we are here at home and the rest of you
that are out there that are working and
building and producing and creating and
leading
keep bleeding.
Keep stepping up,
keep taking on challenges,
and keep striving to
do more and to be more,
keep picking up the pace and keep pushing
harder and no matter what the odds or
what the probabilities,
keep getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.